Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen liebe. Guten Morgen Tim.
Chlorhühnchen verspeist.
Ich bin Vegetarier.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik, die hundertdreißigste Ausgabe, Vegetarier, langweilige Ausrede. Ein Klon, muss man auch genießen.
Ja, mag sein. Ich kann ja, vielleicht gibt's da einen schönen Chlorsalat oder so für mich, oder?
Ja, einen schönen Nachgeschmack.
Chlorburger.
Kapitalistischer Nachgeschmack. Aber.
Jetzt wieder Kommentare.
Uns das gesagt von unserem Gast.
Genau, es gab Shelte.
So, der Gast ist Katharina.
Und ja, herzlich willkommen bei äh Logbuch Netzpolitik. Wir haben dich mal eingeladen, weil wir ja äh Expertise ähm.
Es ermangelte, es mangelte uns an Expertise, hatten wir den Eindruck, nämlich ähm zu TTIP, da wollen wir heute auch drüber sprechen mit dir. Ähm aber wir wollten die Sendung heute,
Eigentlich erstmal mit Feedback einleiten, oder?
Ja, ich äh möchte versuchen, das jetzt öfter zu machen, weil wir regelmäßig äh in der in der glücklichen Situation sind, dass bei uns inhaltlich ergänzende und sinnvolle Kommentare
stattfinden im auf Lokbuchnetzpolitik DE, teilweise sogar auch auf Facebook, da muss ich dann auch nochmal äh.
Also du hast uns ja auf Facebook gesetzt. Liest du das auch? Sind wir da wirklich.
Hast du das auch getan? In Zukunft werde ich das tun. Mir war das schon wieder komplett entfallen. Ich bekenne mich. Ich bin ja Facebook-Agnus.
Ich bekenne mich ähm ich bekenne mich zum zur.
Das das wo ich bekenne mich dazu, das Treiben auf Facebook wohlwollend zu begleiten.
Nee, nee, das.
Immer wenn ich da, wenn ich da reinschaue, sehe ich nur, dass Leute Geburtstag haben, die ich nicht kenne, dass Menschen irgendwelche Beziehungen angefangen haben, die mich nicht interessieren. Ich habe Freunde auf Facebook.
Wenn man Account macht, muss man ja also.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie liken geht. Das ist das wird von meinem Java Skript Blogger irgendwie kaputt gemacht, egal. Ist auch egal. Also, wir haben eine Facebook-Seite, da kann man auch.
Genau, wir stehen, wir stehen über den Dingen auf.
Tim präferiert den Kommentar bei Logbuch Netzpolitik DE
Punkt. M Punkt kommentierte. Heute hattet ihr aber beide mal euren schlechten Tag
den ich eben zugestehe, oder? Einmal Tim, beim Fall sächsische Polizei bei Kriminalität gegen Migranten nachlässig und Linus,
zum Thema General Private Schlüssel für Geheimdienste. Denn dort sollte aus meiner Sicht doch nicht unerwähnt bleiben, dass man, wenn man allen Nachrichten innerhalb eines Landes noch den Generalschlüssel für den Geheimdiensten mit
dadurch eine zusätzliche äh Schwachstelle einbaut. Ähm
kommt nämlich der äh private des Geheimdienstes zu Tage, sind dann plötzlich landesweit,
Mediendienst weit alle verschlüsselten Nachrichten zu öffnen. Damit hast du Recht,
es ist eine auf meine große Nachlässigkeit in der letzten Woche zu schieben, dass ich das nicht äh vernünftig darauf hingewiesen habe.
Das war jetzt nochmal meine Nachlässigkeit.
Nachlässigkeit war, weiß ich nicht, da steht einfach nur in welchem Themenbereich.
Ich fahr einfach nur nachlässig.
Einfach grundsätzlich nachlässig in dem gesamten Themenbereich.
War auch ein bisschen müde letztes Mal.
Ja gut, dass ihr die fünf Schweigeminuten äh aus Trauer und Buße schon vorher gemacht habt. Dann können wir ja jetzt weitermachen.
Genau, also wichtiger wichtiger Punkt natürlich, dass äh
wenn man solche Backdoors äh einbaut und sie uns sie sichert, dass man natürlich trotzdem das Problem hat, dass dann dieser,
das ist wichtig, dass an der Stelle auch nochmal,
anzubringen. Deswegen habe ich ja auch äh aus aus reiner Buße dann einen äh einen Artikel im weißen Motherboard geschrieben. Kennst du weiß Tim, weiß ist lustig. Das ist so ein ähm.
Ein Schreimagazin.
Ja, das liegt in äh in den coolen äh Cafes und Klamottenläden aus und ist ein eigentlich ein sehr amüsantes Magazin,
Arroganz, so 'ne Kokserarroganz, die irgendwie über alles nieistisch einfach nur Witze macht.
Ja. Das mag ich ja eigentlich. Also ein bisschen auf den Kacke hauen und so, dass die.
Eis eigentlich ganz ganz amüsant. Ähm aber.
Und wird angereichert teilweise mit sehr krassen ähm,
sehr krassen äh Dokumentationen und so
ähm über Dinge, die die Leute getan haben. Ich glaube, das letzte Mal auf der letzte Artikel, den ich auf Weiß dot com ähm gelesen habe, war ich äh weil der war auf Englisch, aber Titel war der Titel war ungefähr
Ich habe Koks-Anal konsumiert, damit du es nicht tun musst.
In den verlinkt ist, wo ich dann also sage, es gibt erstens,
bei diesen Kryptowurst eher auf die Dienstanbieter, nämlich äh
so iMessage, WhatsApp, Threema und so die jetzt alle ähm ihre Sicherheit erhöht haben und damit den Geheimdiensten tatsächlich ähm eine Menge Daten aus ihrer äh aus ihrem Datenschleppnetz entzogen haben.
Beziehungsweise im Falle von Skrima war das von vorneherein schon auf dem hohen Niveau. Die anderen haben jetzt nachgerüstet.
Genau, so und das heißt quasi ähm eigentlich ist das der Ritterschlag dafür, dass diese ganzen.
Tools auch helfen.
Dass diese ganzen Schritte, die jetzt von den Dienstanbietern unternommen werden, tatsächlich wirksam sind.
Sich äh ein System bedienen, wo dann selbst der Dienstanbieter keine Vektor mehr reinbauen kann, dass sie diejenigen mit einem Staatstrojaner infizieren wollen.
Das ist, denke ich, der äh der Weg, in den diese Krypto äh Wars jetzt hier ähm einschlagen werden,
Vorratsdatenspeicherung
drin, weil ohne die bringt das alles nichts. Aber letztendlich geht's ihnen darum, dass sie bei den Massenkommunikationsmitteln den Zugriff,
halten wollen und bei denen äh Nischen besonders sicheren Sachen die Leute trojanisieren wollen.
Ich habe das jetzt im Nachgang nicht so äh verfolgt, aber ähm ist ganz interessant, wohin diese Vorratsdatenspeicherungsdebatte äh in Bezug auf dieses Charlie Ep Dot auch noch hin abbiegt. Ich meine, so dass ähm.
Das Feld der Kritiker, ja, das leben wir ja auch gehören.
Was hat man im Nachhinein alles noch recherchieren können? Ja, es gab ja dann diese Vorfälle. In Belgien, tatsächlich, also oder zumindest.
Wurde offiziell gesagt, dass dort ein Anschlag verhindert worden wäre. Äh quasi dieses Untersuchen des Unterstützerumfeldes äh auf Basis von Telekommunikationsdatenanalyse
Ist gut ist schlecht. Ich sage nur, das ist die Debatte, die an der Stelle geführt wird und das sollte man sich auf jeden Fall nochmal genauer anschauen.
Ja obwohl da muss man ja auch ähm im Blick behalten, dass die meisten Gruppen, die jetzt so ein bisschen ausgehoben wurden,
schon seit langem beobachtet wurden.
Die äh Attentäter in Paris.
Genau, genau. Also es wird gesagt, ja, wir haben halt so viele auf der Beobachtungsliste, deshalb konnten wir die jetzt grade persönlich nicht überwachen, was ja eher dafür widerspricht, ähm mehr Geld, sage ich mal, in ja gut, vielleicht nicht Geheimdienste, aber vielleicht polizeiliche Arbeit einfach.
Mein Lieblingssatz zum Thema Vorratsdatenspeicherung, aber Linus, führ doch noch mal auf. Einen haben wir noch.
Neben meinem Kommentar bei weiß, gab es dann von,
Konstanze kurz noch einen Artikel äh in der Frankfurter Allgemeinen Zeitung mit dem Titel die digitale Wohnung und ihr staatlicher Nachschlüssel
und ein Kommentar von Frank Rieger, die Krypto Wars drei Punkt null sind ein Kampf um den Erhalt der Demokratie.
Sprecherteam hat sozusagen auf allen Rohren gefeuert.
Ja
Du hast hier, du hast dich in den Boulevard begeben.
Ja, passt irgendwie auch. Ja. Was kommt als nächstes?
Na ja, ich fand's ich wurde von Heise ja gebeten, gerne saftig und meinungsstark zu schreiben und deshalb, das habe ich dann auch mal versucht. Hat Spaß gemacht. Ich habe ja lange nicht mehr.
Von weiß wurdest du gebeten das zu tun. Ja du hast heise gesagt.
Heise würde wahrscheinlich sowas auch nicht sagen, ne.
Was was wären jetzt so so ein so eine saftige Anekdote aus dem Artikel, um Leuten nochmal so ein bisschen das anzupreisen? Ich kann mir das nicht so vorstellen.
Na, ja, ich habe ja früher habe ich ja mehr geschrieben und ich habe deshalb nicht so lange gedauert, bis mir da wieder äh kleine,
Spitzfindigkeiten in der äh eingefallen sind, die ich dann so geschrieben habe.
Nein, aber ich will ja, dass die Leute zu Weiß gehen und das lesen.
Ähm deswegen äh macht das mal. Aber.
Es wird hier nur geteasert da.
Kein Kokain konsumiert für diesen Artikel.
Auch nicht anal.
Jetzt ist, glaube ich, der Zeitpunkt gekommen, das nächste Thema anzuschneiden.
Genau, äh ein weiterer Kommentar war nämlich, von Patrick, wenn ihr nächste Woche bei TTIP redet,
Bitte lenkt nicht nur den Fokus auf die bösen Amerikaner, äh der ja da,
die das bei uns vertreiben wollen, sondern redet auch darüber, dass Europa auf der anderen Seite des Teiches versucht, Bankengesetze aufzuweichen. Das ist ein Kommentar für dich, liebe Katta. Und damit springen wir, glaube ich, zum Thema, oder?
Ja, also ähm muss ich sagen, Respekt an äh euren eure Kommentarspalte. Ähm die Leute haben wirklich Ahnung.
Denn das ist tatsächlich ein wichtiger Punkt, was viele nicht wissen, ähm nach der Finanz,
rise wurde in den USA viel stärker in den Banken durchreguliert. Das passt europäischen Banken nicht so gerne.
Durch die wollen sie da auch so eine kleine Hintertür haben. Das heißt, ähm na ja, das ist halt,
nicht so einfach, dass man sagen kann, boah, die Amerikaner wollen das jetzt unbedingt und es wird nur den müssen und die Europäer nicht, das ist halt eher so eine Frage zwischen Interessengruppen in der Wirtschaft und Politik, beidseitig.
Bevor wir ähm voll in TTIP einsteigen, vielleicht nochmal
kurz ähm zu dir werde ich nicht äh kennt, du bist ja schon sehr lange im politischen,
netzpolitischen Umfeld äh unterwegs. Äh ich weiß nicht, seit wann betreibst du das äh alles schon?
Ja, also es hat äh angefangen zweitausendsieben, da sollte mal wieder die Vorratsdatenspeiserung eingeführt werden, beziehungsweise wurde. Das ist ja so ein bisschen wie so eine On-Off-Beziehung. Äh immer so, ja, nein, doch nicht. Und Fleiß und ähm.
Bist du ein radikalisiert.
Radikalisierung durchs Internet, dann hat es auch noch die falschen Freunde natürlich, in der radikalen äh Linken, Studierenden
Szene, ähm dann hat's sich ja aka Vorrat, Münster
gegründet und wir haben als erstes direkt eine Demo organisiert und ich habe ihren Seitenbus dort getroffen, damals war er, glaube ich, Vorsitzender der Piratenpartei.
Ist der legendär.
Und hast du gesagt, die brauchen Hilfe, Hilfe.
Nee, da dachte ich, das ist cool. Äh das wir müssen was tun und dann haben wir was getan. Dann müsst ihr dabei geblieben,
und ähm ja, so treibt mich seit zweitausendsieben in unterschiedlichen Zusammenhängen rum,
für mich ist nach wie vor gerade Vorratsdatenspeisung, Massenüberwachung ähm ein riesen Thema.
Mhm. Das äh machst du jetzt bei bei Camp-Act auch kann man schon fast sagen, hauptamtlich.
Ja, es ist ein Beruf. Ja.
Ja. Genau, also bis Kampagne Campänerin, sag mal so.
Campaignerin.
Genau, Campaignerin. Ähm zusammen wahrscheinlich noch mit anderen äh Mitstreiterinnen.
Genau, genau.
Äh wie hieß noch äh die Dame, mit der du zusammen aufm Kongress den Vortrag gehalten hast? Das Marita.
Maritta Strasser. Ähm Maritza ähm hat's,
und äh sie war auch diejenige, die ähm in Folge dessen, obwohl da muss man fairerweise sagen, man weiß nicht so genau, warum sie jetzt nicht mehr in die USA einreisen darf und kein Visum mehr bekommt. Vielleicht ist es wie ein TTIP, vielleicht ist es wegen CETA, aber vorher hat sie halt auch die Snowden-Kampagne betreut
die Geheimdienstkampagne von Nahrung, man weiß es nicht so genau. Ja. Ist ein cooler Job, wie man sieht, ja. Hat man nur Vorteile von.
Reisefreiheit.
Reisefreiheit beispielsweise, ja, aber nach Tibet durfte sie von der Hanne, ja.
Gut, ähm ja, jetzt also TTIM steht bei dir im äh im Fokus, beziehungsweise wahrscheinlich nicht nur TTIP, sondern im Prinzip alle ähm.
Abkommen dieser Art, was ja auch nichts Neues ist. Es gibt immer so ein bisschen diese Wahrnehmung, dass TTIP auf einmal so über uns ähm,
nach dem äh Akte nicht es nicht geschafft hat. Aber die Geschichte der äh sogenannten Freihandels,
kommen ist ja im Prinzip sehr viel länger und auch
sehr viel älter, da kann man jetzt im Prinzip beliebig weit zurückblättern. Es gibt im Übrigen, können wir auch nochmal darauf hinweisen, einen ganz interessanten Beitrag bei HR zwei der Tag, den diese Woche äh erschienen ist. Da sind auch nochmal so ein paar Ausflüge in die ähm Vergangenheit,
auch spezifisch auch in die deutsche Vergangenheit, also auch so die Vereinigung äh des äh ursprünglichen Deutschen,
ähm Zusammenschlusses und so weiter ist halt ja auch von solchen Abkommen,
geprägt, aber ich will jetzt nicht so sehr in der Vergangenheit rumrühren, aber was muss man denn jetzt, um TTIP in seiner Entwicklung zu verstehen, Prinzip vorher noch auch,
oder was muss man damit mit sehen, also welche Entwicklungen haben dazu geführt, dass es jetzt um TTIP geht, wo es vorher um andere Abkürzungen ging.
Ähm solche Handelsabkommen ähm überhaupt,
verhandeln, sonst vorher haben das die einzelnen Staaten, die einzelnen Parlamente, die einzelnen Regierungen gemacht und seit zweitausendneun ähm ist diese Kompetenz eben ähm auf die EU-Ebene übergegangen.
Und ähm was ein großer Kritikpunkt ist ähm von eigentlich allen Handelsabkommen, also man muss es wirklich trennen, also es ist halt einmal und das stand auch in eurem sehr klugen Kommentaren übrigens, also die Leute haben da echt
sich mit auseinandergesetzt. Es geht einmal um den Abbau von ähm sogenannte,
sind.
Also ja Zölle, sage ich mal, ne.
Tarifäre.
Genau, Tarifare, also ich habe auch VWL zu studiert, äh deshalb finde ich, dass ich weiß, wovon ich spreche, ich bin eine sogenannte Expertin,
Genau und ähm nichtariffaire Handelshemmnisse können jetzt alles mögliche sein. Also es ist, da fallen halt,
beispielsweise auch Subventionen drunter, alles Mögliche,
und ähm das muss man immer bedenken. Also es geht halt nicht um Zölle, also nicht nur um Zölle, es geht halt beispielsweise auch darum, so na ja, was für eine Form von,
Fleisch oder Niss, obwohl es Claudia jetzt nicht das aktuellste Beispiel ist und vielleicht auch nicht das Treffenste.
Ganz heißes Eisen. Lass uns dieses Chlorhühnchen einfach rauslassen.
Ähm ja, das ist so ein bisschen
Da gibt's so ein Sprichwort, also das im Raum. Also um's nochmal zu sagen, das glaube ich nicht und ist weitgehend raus so. Also ich würd's einfach nicht mehr verwenden wollen. Es gibt aber viel, viel schlimmere Sachen in diesen Abkommen,
ähm und ein großer Punkt und das ist der zweite Teil, sondern in diesen Handelsgeschichten ähm und Standardgeschichten eben Schießgerichte.
Und vielleicht anderen Leuten mal ein irgendwie so voll die Stirn drücken,
denn das ist eine Paralleljustiz. Das ist so eine Art Supergrundrecht auf Investitionsschutz für.
Für private Investoren, also für Konzerne. Und also,
wie kann man sich das vorstellen? Wie funktioniert das? Normalerweise, wenn es ein Problem hat,
dann gehst nicht hin und sag ey Land ist doch ein Problem, obwohl mache ich's vielleicht, das macht mein Lobbyist,
sondern ähm wenn das so richtig Hardcore klären will, dann gehe ich vor Gericht, ja.
So. Ähm.
Bei solchen Schiedsgerichten ist es so, es ist quasi nochmal eine neue Instanz aufmacht, auf der ich vor Gericht ziehen kann und das ist dann kein normales Gericht, wo normale Richter und normale Rechtsprechung ist, sondern das ist halt wirklich ein,
Privatgerüst, das ist das sind Privatpersonen, die ähm,
sich zusammensetzen und auf Basis der Verträge rechts sprechen. Das heißt, ich kann mich da halt nicht äh so großartig auf andere auf anderes Recht berufen, beispielsweise das Recht, was die letzten,
hundert Jahre hier so in geschichtlichen Zusammenhängen entstanden ist, sondern ähm das ist wirklich nur das, was dort ausverhandelt wurde,
und dann kann ein Investor sagen, so naja, ich hatte jetzt eine, ich habe jetzt eigentlich erwartet, dass die Subventionen länger bleiben oder ich habe jetzt eigentlich erwartet, ähm,
Und ich finde das scheiße, dass sie mir jetzt diese Firma wieder wegnehmen wollt, ihr blödes, demokratisches Regime und dann kann ich anfangen, ähm zu klagen und sagen, ich möchte Schadensersatz haben.
Aber das ist jetzt auch nichts Neues, das gibt es schon. Im Rahmen von anderen Abkommen.
Genau, also es ist ähm also das kann zusammengehen, also es gibt viele Handelsabkommen, die so eine Klausel, so eine ist eine Klausel drin haben,
aber auch diesen Investitionsschutz einzeln. Das sind so die sogenannten,
Bits, also bilaterale Investitionsabkommen, äh wo es halt wirklich nicht um Handel geht, sondern halt wirklich nur um diesen Investitionsschutz. Und ähm da gibt es ähm insgesamt mehr als dreitausend Abkommen weltweit.
Jetzt gab's ja äh letzte Woche hatten wir darüber gesprochen, diese kritische Äußerung von dem ehemaligen Verfassungs äh Richter, wie hieß er noch gleich? Habe den Namen gerade nicht äh parat mitbekommen haben von dieser
Meinungsäußerung,
das ja alles überhaupt nicht vereinbar wäre, also der Bezug sich, glaube ich, konkret auf die Schiedsgerichte, wie sie jetzt bei TTIP geplant sind, aber das würde ja dann im Prinzip auch für die bisher geschlossenen Freihandelsabkommen
gelten.
Also ähm das Problem ist halt, dass normalerweise man ja sagt, das Verfassungsgericht oder halt weiß
nicht europäischer Gerichtshof oder so, ne? Das ist die höchste Instanz, so heißt es. Die haben die größte Credibility und ähm die sprechen ein Recht. Und bei Schiedsgerichten ist es dann so, dass selbst wenn es vom Verfassungsgericht dann halt irgendwie
Die sagen, nö, ist nicht,
sprechen. Und das wird international durchgesetzt aufgrund zu einer Parallel,
Komm, Justiz, ja? Es wird weltweit vollzogen. Das heißt, das ist,
ist quasi wie so eine zusätzliche Decke, die über dem normalen Rechtssystem eingezogen wird. Und das ist, also er hat absolut recht. Ich finde das schade, dass der gute Mann ähm nicht mehr rechts spricht, ja,
weil ähm ich teile absolut seine Meinung, dass hier,
nicht auf Eis, die S berufen und sagen so ähm Amerika, ich finde Gesetz XY ähm irgendwie suboptimal,
Ich fühle mich jetzt also irgendwie Verbraucherstandard X Y Z ist meinen Bedürfnissen nicht angemessen. Ich habe was anderes erwartet, als ich die Creme gekauft habe,
So funktioniert das nicht. Das funktioniert nur für Investoren und Investoren haben auch nur Rechte und keine Pflichten,
und ähm das ist ein echt krass,
stranges Konstrukt, was aus meiner Sicht mit Demokratie an sich nicht vereinbar ist.
Aber jetzt muss ich ja mal Avocado Avocados Diaboli spielen, denn.
Ähm wir hatten das in der letzten Sendung ja schon angesprochen, dass Deutschland als der Erfinder solcher Schiedsgerichte gilt
und ähm der Fall, auf den das zurückgeht, ist, glaube ich, irgendwie neunzehnhundertneunundfünfzig bei irgendwelchen Investitionen oder äh Projekten
Pakistan. Und da hat sich Deutschland gedacht, ey, wenn wir,
Ähm dann hoffen wir natürlich damit irgendwie auch äh unseren Profit machen zu können, den wir mit diesen Investitionen anstreben
Und wenn wir mit diesem Land irgendwie Geschäfte machen wollen, das so instabil ist, dann ist es für uns wichtig,
irgendwie eine vertragliche Basis zu finden, die uns diese Stabilität garantiert,
Also du hast eben keine Ahnung. Ich ich möchte,
irgendwas in einem in einem relativ instabilen Land machen, bei dem ich mich nicht darauf verlassen kann, dass die äh Gesetzeslage so bleibt, wie sie ist,
und ein Beispiel wäre ja, du hast jetzt gerade schon äh angesprochen, dass ich ähm in,
ähm Arabien äh irgendwo investiere und dann äh,
stehen auf einmal ein paar Millionen Leute auf und prügeln den Präsidenten aus seinem Palast raus.
Den Diktator. Ja.
Den rechtmäßigen Herrscher.
Den rechtmäßigen äh gottgegebenen Herrscher äh aus seinem,
zustehenden äh Heiligenpalast äh raus, ja? Und ähm dann kommen auf einmal irgendwelche andere Leute an die Macht und schmeißen einfach mal alle Gesetze über Bord,
und handeln sich nicht mehr an das Abkommen, was ich mit diesem
Land hatte. Das ja jetzt völkerrechtlich durchaus eine interessante Frage,
für so und es gibt ja, weil du jetzt grade sagst, normalerweise sprechen die äh, sprechen die äh die höchsten Gerichte. Das letzte Wort.
Wenn jetzt aber quasi so ein gesamtes Regime umgeworfen wurde, dann kann ich mir auch vorstellen, was ich als deutscher ähm.
Als deutscher Investor äh oder als deutscher Produzent, als deutscher Wirtschaftsakteur, ähm vor diesem neuen,
handeln. Und da ist es doch einleuchtend, dass man sagt, okay, wir müssen wir wollen um diese Handelsbeziehungen.
Zu stabilisieren, ein irgendwie ein völkerrechtliches Abkommen haben, zwischen zwei Staaten. Das verbindlich ist und dadurch sichert, dass sich die Bedingungen unter den Investitionen getätigt werden, nicht wieder ändern.
Denn die Folge davon ist ja, dass nur dann.
Bei instabilen Ländern, ja, nur dann ähm,
du davon ausgehen kannst, dass das überhaupt auch Leute hingehen und Investitionen tätigen, insofern glaube ich, dass in einem Fall von
Instabilität, das durchaus dazu führen würde, dass,
die wirtschaftliche äh Tätigkeit zunimmt.
Ja, also das Argument wird oft gebracht, ähm Hals ist für Bullshit, weil ähm also es gibt mittlerweile Studien, die haben sich angeschaut, wie ist denn das eigentlich so mit den ähm Ländern, die ähm beispielsweise keine
Schiedsgerichte wollen wir nicht. Wir akzeptieren keine Abkommen ähm mit so einem Dreck. Ähm da gibt's einige Länder, die es gemacht haben, beispielsweise Brasilien ist überhaupt gar kein Freund von,
Schiedsgerichten ist halt mittlerweile unter den Brix-Staaten, war mal eine Zeit lang anders, ja?
Und ähm die Direktinvestitionen sind extrem hoch, die höchsten in Südamerika,
von der hinkt der Vergleichs. Zweiter Punkt, ähm wenn man sagt,
ja Regimewechsel ähm schlimm. Was tue ich da?
Naja, dann würde ich sagen, das ist halt, das ist wirklich riesig wo, also es gibt einen Grund, warum halt ähm in bestimmten,
bestimmte Anlageformen, sage ich mal, eine größere Rendite abwerfen, das ist halt immer, sage ich mal, im Idealfall in der ökonomischen Theorie irgendwo eine Ausgleichszahlung für das Risiko, was du hast, ne? Also, weiß ich nicht, wenn ich
Renditen von bis zu hundert Prozent irgendwo in der Bahn so eine geile Pro-Con jetzt kaufen, soundso viel Prozent, da muss ich eben auch davon ausgehen, so, naja, es wird schon seinen Grund haben. So, sonst würden's ja alle machen, ähm da ist wahrscheinlich ein Risiko bei.
Und genauso ist es halt bei vielen Ländern.
Würde ich erstmal sagen, ist unternehmerisches Risiko, wenn man das nicht machen will, dann sollte man,
bei einem Regimewechsel ist es ja nicht so, dass das neue Regime, also da kommen jetzt die Roten quer und sagen halt, ähm ne, Kopf ab,
für alle. Fünfzig Prozent der Bevölkerung, die nichts von Gott gegeben sind. Ähm.
Es ist ja meistens nicht so, sondern ähm also gerade beim arabischen Frühling ist es ja tatsächlich so, dass da demokratisch gewählt wurde
und ein neues Regime ist Jan ich in erster Linie dran interessiert alle,
Investoren aus dem Land zu kicken und ähm irgendwie Arbeitsplätze zu äh vernichten und so weiter und so fort, sondern die wollen die erhalten.
Das heißt, in den meisten Fällen, wenn ich äh nix zu also wenn ich halt jetzt äh nicht krasse Scheiße gebaut habe und ähm zehn Regierungsbeamte vorher geschmiert habe, die mit Koks abgefüllt habe und ein Stück lokal geschickt habe, damit es halt irgendwie den öffentlichen Auftrag krieg,
neunzig Prozent der Fälle wahrscheinlich eher weniger zu befürchten,
und ähm das Interessante ist, dass wenn man sich anguckt, in welchen Fällen wirklich jetzt in nach dem arabischen Frühling,
Schiedsgerichtsklagen kommen, sind es ihm ganz viele Fälle, wo ich sagen würde, na ja, das Geschäft war nicht ganz sauber,
Also ähm die Bedingungen, unter denen ihr den Zuschlag bekommen habt, waren nicht ganz in Ordnung. Die Bedingungen, unter denen die Leute da für euch gearbeitet haben, waren es auch nicht und ähm,
Also ein, um mal ein krasses Beispiel zu nennen. Ja, es gibt halt ein Unternehmen, das klagt,
allen Ernstes hat Südafrika verklagt, weil sie im Gesetz gemacht haben zur Entschädigung von Apartheids opfern. Ja, wo jeder normale Mensch sagen würde.
The fuck. Also das geht doch nicht. Das ist doch also ne, klar war's damals recht, es war recht, ähm,
in Ordnung sein, dass dass danach eine Regierung das feakst und das nicht nur der Staat, sage ich mal, die Entschädigung trägt, sondern halt auch die Unternehmen, die von dieser Ausbeutung profitiert haben, irgendwo dran.
Was hatte denn das Unternehmen was einzuwenden?
Ja, also es gibt einen Gegenhals äh in.
Wurde das Unternehmen auch selber verpflichtet, eine solche Entschädigungsleistung dann zu leisten oder.
Muss ich eben ja also es ging in dem Fall um den Black Enviroment Empowerment,
da war nicht der italienische und äh luxemburgische Investoren in Südafrika tätig und es waren halt,
Die Bergbauunternehmen mussten eben einen Teil der Schirfrechte an benachteiligte Südafrikaner abgeben und das wollten die einfach nicht, ne?
Ist eine sehr Ausbeutungs äh freudige Branche da unten.
Ja, also und in dem Fall war's dann auch so, dass das Verfahren zweitausendzehn ähm eingestellt wurde, ähm,
trotzdem bleibt der Staat auf den hochenden Einwalzkosten von mehreren Millionen
Dollar sitzen und es gibt auch ganz viele Fälle
einfach mal im Vorfeld so ein bisschen vorgeführt wird, gesagt wird, so, ja, wir könnten klagen oder wir klagen, aber na ja, wenn ihr uns jetzt entgegenkommt, dann dann lassen wir das mal fallen. Also so.
Spart ihr euch schon mal so die Begleitkosten?
Sogar in Deutschland. Das war nämlich der erste Fall in dem,
gibt zwei Schießgerichtsklagen von Vattenfall Deutschland. Ähm das eine war wegen so einem ähm Kohlekraftwerk in Hamburg Moorburg,
Das hat so ähm ganz ultra sauberes Wasser in die Elbe geleitet,
neue Auflagen gemacht. Und ähm ja, hat Vattenfall gesagt, so, nö, machen, dann war Scheiße, wollen wir klagen?
Können sie auch auf Basis der Energiekater wieder so ein Euro Vertrag und ähm da hat die Stadt gesagt, das ist uns zu heikel.
Haben dann die Umweltauflagen so unauffällig wieder abgesenkt. Das heißt, es muss gar nicht mal zu Klage kommen, allein, dass dieser Elefant im Raum steht, reicht schon, dass aller eingeschüchtert in die Ecke zurückweichen. Und ja, das ist eigentlich so.
Das Prima der Ökonomie ähm über die Politik, das ist eigentlich so der endgültige Ausverkauf.
Energiekater habe ich gerade mal nachgeschlagen, wurde äh Dezember einundneunzig in Den Haag,
genau.
Gucke nur gerade, wer da jetzt eigentlich gerade beteiligt war, aber das zeigt, das ist jetzt wirklich kein neues Phänomen, sondern wir haben ähnliche Vereinbarungen schon seit längerem.
Könnte man natürlich jetzt auch argumentieren, na ja Gott, was ist denn bei TTIP jetzt noch anders?
Ähm
Und ein interessanter Punkt auch nochmal zu zu deinem Einwand ähm Linus, ne, dass das in,
Ähm wie heißt nochmal? Anwalt des Teufels, Avocados, genau. Ähm,
das Interessante ist, wenn man sich die Entwicklung heute anschaut, ist ähm interessant zu sehen, dass viele, viele Regierungen mittlerweile sagen, nee, wir wollen das nicht. Also beispielsweise die australische Regierung hat gesagt, sie möchte in Zukunft keine solchen Verträge mehr unterzeichnen Bolivi.
Zweitausendelf war das.
Okay, die Alte. Ich glaube, die Neue ist ja eher wieder für zu haben.
Ja. Ja, das kann sein, obwohl da man auch sagen muss, dass ähm je mehr Klagen so eine Staat von Las gekleidet kriegt, desto unbeliebter macht man sich eben auch bei der Bevölkerung. Das sind ja Steuergelder, ne?
Ähm,
und natürlich äh Bolivien Ecuador, Venezuela, die haben gleich mehrere Abkommen gekündigt. Argentinien ist ganz krass dran, die haben so viele äh Klagen bekommen wegen ihrer Wirtschaftskrise, dass sie da ähm auch
überhaupt nicht, also die wollen da raus. Ähm Südafrika will gar keine Abkommen mehr unterzeichnen, auch wegen dieser Sache mit dem Bergbauunternehmen,
Indien sagt jetzt auch so, hm, wollen wir prüfen.
Weil es ist ja auch ganz interessant, dass äh diese,
jeweiligen der jeweiligen beteiligten Staaten äh andeutet. Also diese ursprüngliche Beispiel, ich weiß nicht, hat man das jetzt schon genannt, dieser Investorenschutz in Pakistan, also jetzt das Abkommen, was da mit Deutschland
wurde, soll ja im Prinzip sicherstellen, dass im Wesentlichen
Investition in Pakistan geschützt sind,
Investitionen, die jetzt in die andere Richtung gehen, dürften wahrscheinlich sehr überschaubar gewesen sein, ja?
Systematik, wenn's jetzt um
so Verträge wie zwischen der EU und Kanada und EU und ähm den USA geht.
Wer ist das Entwicklungsland, fragt man sich dann nicht.
Symmetrie der der Rechtsstaatlichkeit eigentlich äh noch angemessen.
Jahrzehnten war's eben auch bei den Klagen. Also was heißt, ich glaube, ich weiß, dass es bei den Klagen ein ganz klares äh Nord-Süd-Gefälle gab. Also die meisten Klagen kamen aus dem Norden gegen den Süden und waren auch erfolgreich und Studien zeigen, dass,
Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass ähm ein Konzern Recht bekommt, wenn er eben ausm nördlichen Land kommt, einfach sehr hoch ist im Vergleich zum.
Und das war eben, also das ist quasi eine Verrechlichung von der Machtstruktur, also Nord gegen Süd. So, ne? Wir haben mehr Kohle, äh ihr wollt Investitionen so, wir sagen euch, wo es langgeht,
und dieser Spieß wird eben jetzt in eine Richtung umgedreht, ähm wo es gar nicht mehr um Länder geht, sondern um die Beziehung.
Demokratie, Ökonomie, beziehungsweise Konzerne.
Dass ist eine extrem gefährliche Entwicklung einfach. Also.
Es wundert mich nicht, ne? Aber ähm wir sollten da möglichst schnell raus.
Deutschland gilt ja so ein bisschen als Erfinder äh dieser Systematiken. Stimmt das eigentlich?
Ja, das stimmt schon. Also ähm.
Ich kann das jetzt nur auf diese Pakistan-Geschichte zurückführen, aber ich weiß nicht, ob das sozusagen der.
Das ist der dokumentierte erste Fall.
Ja, von daher wär's nur konsequent, wenn man halt auch derjenige wär, der sagt, so.
Ja aber ist doch sehr interessant zu sehen, deshalb machen wir die Bevölkerung in Deutschland jetzt diesen generellen äh also dieser jetzt,
wohldiskutierten oder zumindest bei uns in unseren Kreisen wohl diskutierten äh Geschichte sehr sehr kritisch gegenüber steht und das auch äh so unter vor allem unter diesem Aspekt Verbraucherschutz,
bewertet, zumindest in der Öffentlichkeit habe ich so ein bisschen den Eindruck, ne, so gehen das Böse kommt immer alles aus dem Westen, so also aus dem,
aus den USA, ne. Die wird sich wieder mit Chlorhühnchen anfangen, aber,
Man sieht, glaube ich, da sehr viel mehr Bedrohungspotential. Die Chancen sind natürlich aber vor allem für die deutsche Exportwirtschaft wahrscheinlich auch ein Ding. Ich frage mich, wer würde jetzt wen mehr äh vor Schutzgericht ziehen?
Glaube, also zwei Sachen nun mal. Ich glaube, erstens nicht, dass ich da dass ich ähm,
natürlich eher darauf laufen, dass es ein ähm,
vorauseilenden Gehorsamen gibt und man sich auf beiden, in beiden Ländern.
Um eine Angleichung der Handelsregulation bemühen wird. Das ist ja der, der eigentliche äh Punkt und den es am Ende allen geht. Darum, man will ein Handelshemmnis abbauen,
Das heißt, da damit lässt sich ja eigentlich alles sagen. So, vor allem, wenn die Sorge im Raum steht, dass du nachher halt vor allem mit dem Fall vor irgendeinem Schiedsgericht stehst.
Ähm also,
äh vor Gericht stehen wollen, sondern weil sie sich
vertragen möchten, ja?
Mhm. Schön gesagt.
Ähm insofern glaube ich nicht, dass dass da jetzt irgendwie äh,
jemand andauernd vor vor Schiedsgerichten stehen wird, sondern vielmehr, dass sich,
implizit das einfach ergeben wird, dass eben das, was Handelshemmes ist, abgebaut wird. Und das Ärgerliche ist natürlich, dass.
Umweltstandards und so, großes Handelszentrum, Umweltstandards.
Genau, das äh die meisten Handels, was was formal ein Handelshemmnis ist, in in der Regel aus,
aus bestimmten Gründen da ist, ne, weil man die Umweltschutz schützen möchte,
Hinzu kommt dann eben diese Rechtssicherheit für die Unternehmen und natürlich freut sich ähm Deutschland ganz klar, wenn sie äh irgendwie mit weniger,
Handelsbarrieren, äh Autos in die USA verkaufen können. Und genau davor haben Amerikaner auch Angst. Also es ist nicht so, als würden die Amerikaner.
Wie gesagt, was gerade dieser Kommentar Eingang war, es gibt ja eben auch quasi Bereiche,
ähm in denen äh die europäischen Akteure wollen, dass,
Handelshemmnisse äh auf amerikanischer Seite abgebaut werden. Und ich denke, der der wirkliche ähm
Der wirkliche Wirkmechanismus von so einem Freihandelsabkommen ist, dass jeweils sich in, also dass in beiden Ländern sich jeweils der.
Standard durchsetzen wird oder der das Regulierungsniveau durchsetzen wird.
Ausgeprägt.
Geringer ausgeprägt als in den USA. Also.
Die Regulation ist in USA.
Nee, also nach der Finanzkrise haben die halt wirklich, muss man sagen, mehr aufgeräumt, in einigen Bereichen. Das sind
allen Bereichen natürlich, aber in einigen schon, die halt grade für Investmentbanken interessant sind.
Sind interne Dokumente aufgetaucht, die ihm besagen, dass auch die US-Seite, also die US-Regierung, ähm aktiv,
vorab quasi so als Abo-Service, Newsletter-mäßig ähm über geplante Gesetze auf EU-Ebene informiert werden will, damit man das vorher schon abgleichen kann,
und ähm das ist eben genau dieser Mechanismus, den du also angesprochen hast. Das ist ähm,
dann schreiben die zurück, so nee, passt uns nicht, das da sehen wir jetzt eine Klagemöglichkeit so.
Und das äh,
das, was heute noch Handelshemmnisse sind, sind eben größtenteils,
sowas wie ja Errungenschaften der Zivilgesellschaft, ne, die also,
Umweltschutz, Verbraucherschutz oder so, alles, was irgendwie so noch die die völlige Entfesselung äh des,
des Marktes äh ein bisschen in Grenzen hält, um so ein bisschen Mindeststandards äh noch für das Zusammenleben äh zu haben, ne. Und das, das, das sind Handelshemmnisse. Klar, ganz, also ganz objektiv betrachtet, was meinst du, was ähm.
Was jetzt so Umweltschutzauflagen für Handelshelme sind, wenn du äh sagen wir mal Kohle oder Atomkraftwerke äh betreibst. Gleichzeitig sind sie aber natürlich ähm
für äh die Hersteller von äh allen möglichen Umweltschutzkram. Ja, also irgendwelche Leute, die meinen, wir entwickeln jetzt irgendwie äh unterirdische Kohlendioxidlager oder wir wir gucken mal hier in in dem alten Salzstock, ob wir da nicht der ganze,
das macht's ja letztendlich auch so schwer abschätzbar in welchen Bereichen Deregulierung,
am Ende zu einem Netto Plus führt.
Also nochmal um anderes Beispiel zu nennen, das muss ich noch mal zur Klarheit sagen. Ich habe mal für die Verbraucherzentrale Bundesverband,
arbeitet, ja? Ähm ich bin da nicht ganz neutral, ich bin extrem positiv,
und da gab's ein sehr interessantes Interview vom ähm neuen Vorstand,
gesagt hat so, naja, es geht für uns eben in ganz vielen Bereichen, umso,
allein schon den Prozess, wie Produkte ähm genehmigt oder zugelassen werden. Der ist in den USA eben ganz anders und
Unternehmen wollen eben, dass durch ähm TTIP und andere Abkommen das gegenseitig anerkannt wird. Da kann man sagen, okay, ist halt,
Ja, es ist ein zivilisiertes Land so, das können wir mal machen. Ähm ist aber nicht unproblematisch. Das ganze Rechtssystem im Bereich Verbraucherschutz ist in den USA anders. Dort ähm wird viel weniger vorher kontrolliert,
die Möglichkeit, diese ganzen Massenklagen zu machen. Das heißt, da,
sind andere Anreize für Unternehmen dran, kein Beton in ihre Cornflakes zu mischen, weil wenn da zwanzig Leute draufbeißen und auf Schmerzensgeld klagen sind, sind die dran, ja? Und dann sind die finanziell richtig am Arsch.
Und da diese Systeme einfach so zu mischen und zu sagen so, naja, wir.
Erkenne das jetzt pauschal quer an,
ohne andere Sachen zu bedenken. Ähm ist nicht in Ordnung. Vor allem, weil ihnen, wie gesagt, nur Konzerne können sich drauf berufen, die haben nur Rechte, keine Pflichten, das heißt, die Verbraucherzentrale kann jetzt nicht sagen, so ähm,
unsere äh legitimen Erwartungen wurden jetzt hier nicht erfüllt. Die haben ja auch keine Investitionen getätigt.
Dann wollen wir uns aber doch mal noch so ein paar der,
Bereiche anschauen um dies jetzt da geht.
Also wir haben ja äh also ich erinnere mich zum Beispiel
im Bereich des Datenschutzes an dieses Abkommen. Da habe ich mich aber jetzt nur gerade dran erinnert, weil du ähm weil du das so ansparst, dass es eben in USA einfach ganz anders ist und es im Prinzip
ich will das jetzt gar nicht vertiefen, aber da hast du quasi zwei völlig disjunte, inkompatible Gesetzgebung ähm.
Und Regulationsformen. Du konntest jetzt äh es wäre es einfach nicht denkbar und nicht möglich.
Ja, die Daten sind total sicher, deshalb ja auch safe habe, ist ein sicherer Datenhafen, wo die NSA dann fischt.
Nun das war doch ein der Abbau eines großen Handelshemmnisses für US-amerikanische Cloud-Betreiber. Da kann doch jetzt keiner ähm äh nichts,
Nicht zugeben, dass da äh wirtschaftlich äh äh Wohlstand geschaffen wurde dadurch.
Ja, also ähm wo fange ich da jetzt an?
Ich glaube ähm am wichtigsten wäre es nochmal ähm diesen großen Bogen nochmal zu klären. So ja Mythos, TTIP,
Landschaften, überall in Deutschland und Europa schaffen und wir werden Händchen halten mit unserer Familie, über diese,
Landschaften tanzen und die Sonne geht auf, der Regenbogen, wir haben alle Arbeitsplätze und tausend Euro mehr in der Tasche.
Schön. Hm.
Scheiße passiert nicht. Ähm wurde abgesagt,
Ähm ja, also wo woher kommt dieses äh geile Bild? Natürlich auch sehr,
bei äh ja sagen wir mal live new liberal angehauchten Instit,
Vorsicht ist ausgedrückt und sie haben extrem positive Zahlen,
produziert und groß in die Presse gehauen, so ja, so und so viele hunderttausende Arbeitsplätze, so und so viele Euro mehr im Monat für den Durchschnittsbürger wird's bedeuten und äh ja, ich habe ja VWL studiert,
Ähm ich habe das manchmal bereut, aber das war wie ein Moment, wo ich dachte, so haha. Wie die Studie angeguckt und ähm.
Es war nicht alles schlecht im VWL-Studi.
Nee, also beispielsweise traue keiner Statistik, die dir nicht selbst gefälscht hat. Also Statistik
die Studie ist halt echt äh strange, um es mal vorsichtig zu sagen, die gehen von so einem,
also vorm Computer General Equalivio Modell aus von der Weltbank. Das Vollbeschäftigung Voraussetzung.
Sagen, was ist das für ein Modell? Computer.
Das ist so, also das ist also ähm Computer,
äh also so das Modell der Weltbank, die ist halt,
gibt unterschiedliche Marktmodelle, um halt eben so Simulationen zu machen. Das ist eben das von der Weltbank,
und ja Vollbeschäftigung, Voraussetzung,
finde ich schwierig. Weil,
Naja, ist total unrealistisch. So. Ähm dann zweiter Punkt, äh.
Da wird ein Durchschnittswert berechnet, wie viel TTIP uns allen bringen soll. Das ist ein Durchschnittswert, ja. Es ist halt keine Aussage gemacht, wie dieser,
Mehrwert sich verteilt zwischen Produzenten und Konsumentenrente, also zwischen Konzernen und Menschen, das heißt, selbst wenn wir total verlieren durch dieses Abkommen, ähm Konzerne, aber,
sagt überhaupt nichts aus. Und ja.
Dritter Punkt, äh ist so ein bisschen die Zahl an sich,
wenn man das mal aufs wöchentliche Wachstum pro Jahr runterrechnet, was da rausgekommen sind,
ähm durch TTIP, also durch einen erfolgreichen Abschluss von TTIP,
in dem krassesten Ausmaß, was verhandelt wird, also ne, Schiedsgerichte achtundneunzig Prozent der Steuern abbauen so, ne? Maximal äh null Komma null fünf Prozent,
Wachstum jährlich. So, das ist ein Witz. Und die zweite Studie ist halt hm,
also ich glaube, dass die These, dass wir alle blühende Landschaften durch diese Abkommen haben werden, ist
totaler Bullshit. Das wird nicht passieren,
Was wahrscheinlicher ist, ist ähm ein anderer Fall und zwar, dass ähm ja, wir wir als Verbraucher einfach wahrscheinlich nicht davon profitieren werden. Das ist halt etwas, was ähm Konzerne,
bevorteilt, benachteilt. Mir ist als Person, ehrlich gesagt, ähm total egal, wo der Konzern sitzt, der davon profitiert auch und ob auf dieser oder nicht,
auf der anderen Seite des Atlantiks. Ähm die Tatsache ist halt, dass es halt auf Kosten der Demokratie und auch auf Kosten der Arbeitnehmer.
Gehen wird.
Netzpolitischen Aspekte, die sich jetzt aus dieser ganzen TTIP-Diskussion vielleicht gewinnen lassen äh in den Mittelpunkt stellen. Also welche Bereiche siehst du denn da,
sagen wir mal hier auch so ein bisschen mehr in unser Kernthema reinfallen, die jetzt mehr oder weniger unmittelbar berührt.
Hm. Ja, also es gibt ja unterschiedliche Abkommen, da muss man auch sehr stark unterscheiden,
Ich glaube, was ähm den meisten vielleicht auch ein Begriff sein könnte, weil das auch ziemlich prominent auf Netzpolitik,
laufen ist, ist ähm Kieser, das ist nochmal so ein anderes Handels.
Trade in Services Agreement.
Genau. Das soll ähm beispielsweise laut der ähm Verhandlungsführerin wie wir in
EU-Parlament äh ein richtiger Kracher sein. Also sie warnt, die Berichterstatterin selbst ist Parlaments, warnt davor, dass hier großflächig Datenschutz ausgehebelt werden
auf welcher Grundlage ähm es gab ein paar Leaks, die ähm so erste Entwurfsstadien der Dokument,
inhalten. Und normalerweise selbst in den äh Chitics Abkommen
Gibt es Ausnahmeklauseln, die dann so vorne drin stehen, so, ne, also bevor das Ganze irgendwie losgeht, wird gesagt, so ja, ähm na, na, na, na, das folgende, bla, la, la, la, la, Vertrag, Vertrag. Ähm,
Aber in folgenden Punkten können Staaten halt auch mal sagen, so, hm, machen wir eine Ausnahme. Beispielsweise private Protection.
Datenschutz, Datensicherheit, frei übersetzt. Äh dieser Punkt fehlt da vollkommen. Also selbst die Gummiklausel, die sonst immer drin ist,
fehlt schon. Und die Gummiklausel ist auch nicht wirklich sicher. Also die sichert jetzt nicht den Datenschutz in solchen Abkommen, aber wenn selbst die Gummiklausel in so einem Vertrag fehlt, ähm ja, schwierig.
Uns, ähm um nochmal konkreter zu werden. Bei TTIP ist es beispielsweise so, dass ähm also beim Abkommen zwischen der EU und den USA,
Da gab's ein Leak ähm fürs Kapitel E-Commerce, was für mich sehr praktisch war, weil mich das auch besonders interessiert. Ich hab's mir durchgelesen und dann gibt's auch interessante,
Analysen, unter anderem von Ante Wessels und ähm.
Wenn man dieses Abkommen mit anderen Abkommen vergleichst, sind dort einzelne Punkte grade beim ähm Thema,
free Data Flows, also beim freien Datenfluss,
im Bereich der Finanzwerk so so,
Was generell erstmal so den kompletten E-Commerce-Bereich betrifft, weil irgendwo fallen ja immer Transaktionen an. Und so eine ähnliche Klausel, wie sie in diesem
E-Commerce-Kapel steht, gab's schon mal, in einem Kapitel zwischen EU und Südkorea. Und das hat dazu geführt
Diese eine Klausel, das in dem Fall damals die EU gesagt hat, so naja Südkorea, wir finden das jetzt nicht so cool, dass eure Banken, ihre Kunden jedes Mal fragen und informieren, wenn ihre Finanzdaten außerhalb von Südkorea gespeichert werden.
Was hat das jetzt mit Netzneutralität zu tun.
Das hat mit Netzo, das hat eher was mit Datenschutz zu tun.
Gerade.
NS-Neutralität zahlt auch noch mal eine andere Sache, aber ähm.
Das ist also das Südkorea-Ding ist quasi eher also es das ist ein Datenschutzbeispiel und jetzt auf TTIP bezogen so. Äh Netzneutralität ist eher bei Teaser, würde ich sagen, eher ein Thema, wobei man auch sagen muss, man weiß es halt noch nicht in vielen Punkten bei Tit.
Wie, wie sehr hängen denn jetzt diese Abkommen überhaupt zusammen? Also CETA,
Ist ja weit,
muss, also ob's reicht, ob die EU das macht oder ob die Länder das einzeln machen müssen. TTIP gilt als noch nicht ausverhandelt und
auch nicht. Wie ist das richtig? Aber irgendwie sind es ja ein Paket.
Ja, also ähm es wird halt gesagt, dass da halt schon so eine Agenda gefahren wird. Man möchte halt ein paar Abkommen abschließen und im Endeffekt stehen halt auch noch so ein paar andere,
man so was mit Singapur machen will. Und das sind halt zum Teil auch strategische Fragen, also damit wird auch in der Öffentlichkeit argumentiert, teilweise
so, naja, wenn wir jetzt das, wenn wir jetzt Schiedsgerichte nicht in den Abkommen zwischen USA und EU
reinpacken, dann werden wir das bei China auch nicht durchkriegen und bei China wollen, dass unsere Konzerne aber und da das wird die heimische Wirtschaft ähm richtig in in den Himmel,
katapultieren. Und das ist so die politische, ökonomische Agenda dahinter. Und ähm
Ja, was haben die Abkommen miteinander zu tun? Es ist halt dieselbe Mechanik. Es ist dasselbe Prinzip. Es ist halt ähm meistens,
ISDS mit drin, also dieses Schiedsgerichter. Es geht eben um ähm den
sind überall so. Fast überall,
Kauseln drin, das sind sogenannte ähm Klauseln, die sicherstellen, dass ähm die Liberalisierung auf dem,
liberalst möglichen Stand, den es je da zu dem Zeitpunkt gegeben hat, Festbetoniert werden. Das heißt, beispielsweise es wird schwieriger zu sagen, so naja, wir wollen hier doch mehr Staat, das war doch nicht so ist doch nicht so gut gelaufen.
Kleinste gemeinsame Nenner.
Genau und das ist halt eben also diese neoliberale ähm Grundstimmung ist der gemeinsame Schiedsgericht und halt eben ja die Grundprobleme mit den Standards.
Wenn jetzt so mit äh China gewedelt wird, würde mich mal interessieren, weißt du das? Ähm hat, hat denn auch China entsprechende,
ähnliche Abkommen schon mit anderen Ländern oder,
Grade wieder sehr aufeinander,
mangels der entsprechenden westlichen Liebe äh äh glaube ich vor allem. Ich weiß bloß nicht, ob die auch entsprechende Abkommen,
miteinander haben. Ich meine, nun sehr weder Russland noch noch China besonders bekannt dafür, sich jetzt auf so.
Kann ich ehrlich gesagt mit China habe ich mich noch nicht so intensiv auseinandergesetzt.
Okay, gut. Filmen wir nur gerade so ein. Ähm Ines, hast du noch ähm Fragen oder Anmerkungen,
Würde mich ja nochmal interessieren, was wo du jetzt so ein bisschen.
Gerade das Potenzial siehst, wie man denn auf,
diese Verhandlungsstrategie der EU Einfluss nehmen kann. Also ich denke, was ja so der,
größte Teil ist, der kritisiert wird, ist ja grundsätzlich dieses im geheimen Aushandeln,
Das ist ja irgendwie neu. Ich meine, das ist früher immer so gelaufen,
Heutzutage ist es irgendwie ein Thema. Man man man will da mehr äh Transparenz, man befürchtet eben auch eine Menge,
jetzt kommt es irgendwie alles zusammen. Ich verbuche das jetzt mal auch so unter neuer,
man nicht am Ende vor so 'n fertiges Paket gestellt wird und wo einfach nur noch gesagt wird ob oder top.
Ne, sie legen zumindest alte Zwischenstände äh offen, ob die nun vollständig sind oder so, kann ich nicht bewerten.
Wo siehst du den Einfluss, inwiefern ist das bis das Parlament eigentlich jetzt äh schon mit im Boot? Ist das Problem, die Kommission? Wo sind da gerade die Hebel, die sich anbieten?
Die möglich sind, wirklich den Hebel anzusetzen und das sind gar nicht so wenige.
Sowohl TTIP als auch CETA, als auch dieser sind alles gemischte Abkommen, das heißt da muss nicht nur die Yukon, also es wenn die EU-Kommission überzeugt ist, sie will das unbedingt haben, dann ähm heißt es noch nicht, dass sie es bekommt, also.
Ja klar.
Parlament noch zustimmen. Da muss müssen die einzelnen Regierungen noch zustimmen.
Und dann ist noch die Streitfrage, ob halt auch die einzelnen Länder auch noch zustimmen müssen.
Ratifizierung betrifft.
Genau, würde ich halt so sehen, also beispielsweise muss Hamburg sagen, nach dem großen Erfolg, den man halt mit Vattenfall hatte, so ja, geil, wollen wir mehr von? Stimmen wir im Bundesrat für. Ist halt die Frage.
Nochmal gefragt.
Mich mich würde erstmal die Position des Parlaments jetzt konkret
hört zu?
Wer hört noch nicht zu? Inwiefern ist jetzt hat sich auch in der Kommission jetzt schon so ein bisschen dieser Trend zu, naja, wir wollen jetzt auch mehr veröffentlichen, durchgesetzt, also was ist so,
wie ist das politische System gerade aufgebaut? Wo sind so die,
Verfechter angesiedelt und wo ähm,
sieht's anders aus. Nehmen wir mal an, der europäische Rat ist natürlich so im Wesentlichen so die Verfechter äh Fraktion an, führt wahrscheinlich durch Frau Merkel im Parlament erscheint mir
das etwas kritischer zu sein, aber ich habe keine Ahnung, wie jetzt zum Beispiel die einzelnen europäischen Fraktionen da aufgestellt sind.
Ja, also die Sozialdemokraten beispielsweise sind halt sehr wohlgesonnen gegenüber ähm.
Handelsabkommen. Das sieht beispielsweise in Deutschland bei der Basis anders aus, die will das nicht, aber ähm,
tendenziell nicht. Ich weiß nicht, ob die jetzt in Zensil ja noch ein Begriff ist?
Ja, ja, Frau Malztröm.
Frau Mainström ähm ja, ich habe eine intensive.
Intensiver ähm traumatische Erinnerung an sie noch im Zusammenhang mit der Zensurdebatte, auch mit der Vorratsda,
die es jetzt Handelskommissarin und sie will das Ding unbedingt haben, also,
sage ich mal, diese große PR-Aktion, die jetzt gefahren wird, dass man gesagt hat so, ja, wir nehmen die Bedenken, die Ängste, die Ängste und Sorgen der Bürger total ernst. Die haben zwar nix mit der Realität zu tun, weil Titte, die blühende Landschaft bringen wird.
Und ähm deshalb werden wir jetzt Dokumente veröffentlichen.
Ist bis jetzt noch nicht in der Vollständigkeit passiert, die halt angekündigt wurde,
jeder, der schon mal etwas verhandelt hat, weiß, da kommen zwei Positionen zusammen.
Geht man in Raum und sprichst darüber und einigt sich auf auf eine dritte Sache, die wahrscheinlich ein Kompromiss zwischen beiden,
ist. Und wenn das Ganze hinter geschlossenen Türen stattfindet und wenn ich vorher weiß, dass ich diese,
Bevölkerung irgendwie verkaufen kann. Ähm dann stellt sich natürlich auch die Frage, ob damit strategisch nicht auch gearbeitet wird, dass man sagt so, naja, da,
packen wir mal was rein, hinter verschlossenen Türen kann uns ja eh nichts jemand sagen, ja, das war gar nicht so gemeint, also ja, würden wir gerne haben, wenn der sagt, wollt ihr nicht, dann ja egal.
Nee, aber also ähm wenn zwei Vertragsparteien,
irgendwie ihr Abkommen aushandeln, finde ich das eigentlich schon sehr,
überraschenden Schritt und eigentlich auch ein sehr schön.
Schwierig zu,
zu erklärenden Schritt, dass sie ihre Verhandlungspositionen veröffentlichen müssen. Das ist doch wirklich zum Nachteil. Also wenn man davon ausgeht,
dass dieses Abkommen kommt, ja, dann müsste ich doch eigentlich mir wünschen, dass äh meine Vertragsparteien,
die irgendwie am Ende meine Interessen dabei vertreten sollen, möglichst stark in diese Verhandlung gehen können und nicht
dadurch geschwächt sind, dass sie ihre Position vorher veröffentlichen mussten,
werden muss. Sei es das EU Parlament oder seien es Parlament in jedem einzelnen Land, dann spätestens dann wird ja der Text des Abkommens öffentlich sein müssen. Und da finde ich das Argument, das wird hinter äh verschlossenen Türen ausgehandelt. Ähm zwar zutreffend, aber nicht besonders äh gewichtig.
Ja, doch, also ähm wenn man wirklich also was bedeutet denn Ratifizierung und was was ist Aufgabe des Parlaments? Muss man sich ja auch mal fragen, ist ein Parlament
ja nein Institution, die sagt so, okay, friss oder stirbwal, wir nicken es ab oder lassen es durchfallen
oder ist das Parlament nicht eigentlich auch eher so eine Quasselbude, wo man Argumente austauscht, ne? Und das,
da wird halt wirklich krasser Druck aufgebaut, also entweder wollt ihr das genauso, wie wir's haben oder er bekommt's gar nicht,
Und das ist, glaube ich, nicht der Weg, den man da gehen sollte, sondern man sollte eher sagen so, naja, vielleicht,
Argumente. Vielleicht ähm gibt's einen Kompromiss nicht nur zwischen,
Kommission, also ne, zwischen den beiden Verhandlungsführern, sondern auch vielleicht zwischen den Parlamenten.
Die werden da ja gar nicht einbezogen. Und mit diesem ähm dieser strategischen Frage.
Ähm würde ich noch mal ergänzen, dass wenn man das so ein bisschen spieltheoretisch sieht man sehen muss, dass es halt nicht nur dieses eine Spiel gibt, sage ich mal, zwischen ähm.
Den Verhandlungsführern von USA und EU,
sondern das hat unglaublich viel mehr ebenen. Da gibt es ganz viele andere Interessengruppen. Das ist ja nicht so national,
manchmal einige Interessen teilen, einige nicht, dann gibt es noch die Parlamente, das ist hat unglaublich viel mehr Ebenen und indem du es von Anfang an so framest, dass du sagst, so,
Das ist ein Abkommen zwischen USA und EU und es geht darum, unsere Interessen zu schützen, deshalb müssen wir das geheim halten, dann verzehrst du die Realität,
denn ähm die Interessengruppen, die da mit einbezogen werden müssten, ähm.
Erschließt sich mir nicht, weil jedes andere, also.
Es ist ja also der demokratische Prozess in der Form findet doch an anderen Stellen genauso wenig statt. Also ob ich jetzt im, wenn,
Also ich meine, wir wir reden ja über über nationale Gesetzgebungen häufig. Da werden ja auch also da werden meine persönlichen Interessen ja auch die ganze Zeit nicht berücksichtigt.
Ja, aber du hast zumindest im, ähm, du hast halt zumindest einen geordneten Prozess, sage ich mal, wo du halt ähm
Entwurf hast so und dann äh also deine Referentenentwurf und dann geht
der halt erstmal erste Lesung, Ausschuss, ja, zweite Lesung, Drittlesung, wird das noch im Bundestag so, dann ähm ist der Entwurf öffentlich, dann werden Experten gehört, so dass alles gibt es
bei TTIP nicht.
Genau und aber das.
Abgeordneten im EU-Parlament, pass auf, die darüber abstimmen müssen, die müssen in so einen extra Raum gehen, der abgeschottet ist und da
Dürfen sie die Dokumente lesen? Ja und als Abgeordneter bin ich in neunzig Prozent der Fälle absolut hilflos, ohne meine Mitarbeiter, die mir sagen, was dort eigentlich steht, die vielleicht Juristen sind. So.
So krass ist es nicht.
Gut, aber äh prinzipiell sehe ich da kaum einen Unterschied. Also wenn ich äh in Deutschland mir ein Gesetz anschaue, da werden dann,
das da werden öffentliche Debatten drüber geführt, wo ähm wo Politiker sich so äußern, dass sie möglichst mit einem prägnanten Satz vielleicht in der in der Tagesschau äh kurz eingeblendet werden. Und es gibt irgendwie die,
Diskussionen, die zwischen parlamentariern in den Hinterzimmern stattfinden, einerseits mit anderen Parlamentariern, andererseits mit den Lobbyisten, so. Und am Ende äh sitzt man in einem Hinterzimmer und äh diskutiert
bestimmte bestimmte Fassung aus und die wird dann irgendwann aus diesen kleinen Gremien,
oder intransparenten Abstimmungen irgendwann in dieses
in diesen demokratischen äh in dieses demokratische Malwerk hochgereicht und da findet aber in meinen Augen,
kaum noch Veränderungen statt. Da wird dann halt mal vielleicht irgendwie ein Satz geändert oder oder ein Absatz gestrichen, aber so wirklich
ähm die die Absicht des des tatsächlichen Gesetzes oder so wird ja überhaupt nicht mehr in Frage gestellt und da wird da findet ja jetzt nicht irgendwie da wird ja jetzt nicht am Ende,
das Gesetz in ein Pad gegossen und jeder kann nochmal was reinschreiben. Das ist ja auch nur ein Prozess, der irgendwie so am Ende ähm.
Diesem Produkt der Abstimmung ähm der internen kleinen Abstimmung und äh den,
den äh den Stempel der demokratischen Entscheidungen irgendwann aufdrückt,
Aber so ein also schau dir jetzt zum Beispiel so kann man ja ich es gibt da so ein paar Gesetze, die ich ja irgendwie verfolgt habe und ein paar Gesetze, die ich jetzt gerade verfolge, da gibt's dann immer irgendwie einen neuen Entwurf aus dem ähm.
Aus dem Ministerium, der wurde da geschrieben, den hat doch jetzt, der hat doch keinen äh,
Also da da hat ja jetzt nicht irgendeine Abstimmung mit Parlamentariern stattgefunden, da wird dann irgendwann jetzt so ein E-Health-Gesetz runter.
Das ist eben der Unterschied so, es ist halt ein Entwurf so und dann wird es halt nochmal zur Prüfung an andere Ministerien, an Interessengruppen normalerweise geschickt, damit man sich
vorher absichert. Dann gibt es halt eben das Zeitfenster zwischen Entwurf und halt der dritten Lesung, wo halt die einzelnen Verbände, wenn sie davon, also
zufällig der Entwurf vorliegt, was ja meistens der Fall ist, ähm dass sie halt noch gezielt Druck machen können oder halt, dass der Presse geben können und so weiter und so fort,
Abgeordneten können sich das halt durchlesen, die können ihre Mitarbeiter dran setzen.
Ein Abgeordneter macht das ja neunzig Prozent der Fälle nicht selbst.
TTIP geht es nicht und bei TTIP geht's jetzt nicht um einzelnes Gesetz, sondern also mit den Schiedsgerichten geht's wirklich um die Etablierung einer,
eines Parallelen Rechtssystems und ähm angesichts der Schwere der Entscheidung,
finde ich, sollte man eigentlich mehr Demokratie wagen und nicht weniger und
Das läuft suboptimal, dass du auf jeden Fall recht. Jeder hat seine Basswords, die er dazu halt abnudelt in der in den Tagesthemen und das waren die große Debatte so.
So sollte es nicht laufen, aber ähm TTIP ist einen Schritt zurück und nicht nach vorn. Und eigentlich haben wir doch bei Acta gezeigt, dass wir,
europaweit, Leute mobilisieren können gegen diese Strukturen,
Geheimverhandlung von ähm solchen internationalen Abkommen. So und eigentlich hätte der Lerneffekt sein müssen, ähm das trauen wir uns jetzt nicht mehr.
Interne Dokument, EU-Kommission zeigen, dass Acta der also so ein riesen Thema intern ist. So man hat von Anfang an versucht
kein Vergleich mit aquadierten, unglaublichen Angst, dass es halt wieder so zu so zu Prozessen führt. Aber was machen sie so,
zu sagen, okay, wir gucken uns an, warum sind die Leute bei überhaupt auf die Straße gegangen? So na ja, inhaltlich, ne,
und wegen der Struktur, wie das Ganze gemacht wurde.
Die daraus jetzt aber auch keine Schönheitskollegin machen.
Alles klar. Der der Freihandel Handel.
Handel.
Wollen wir weiter machen?
Von mir aus sehr gerne. Ich glaube, wir haben so viele Aspekte angesprochen und ich glaube, was ich,
Was wir so umschifft haben, ist halt, dass oder was wir was Cutter an mir an Stellen angesprochen hat, aber wir so konkret jetzt,
ähm glaube ich, als Glaubensfrage auch ausgeklammert haben, ist, dass es, dass es wirklich hier ein, dass es ein Paradigma, ne? Das ist ein politisches Paradigma des Neoliberalismus
dass sich in diesen Abkommen manifestiert,
das ähm sich in diesen Abkommen.
Ja auch erweitern wird.
Auge äh langfristig äh so eine Struktur, wo Konzerne eigentlich mehr Macht haben, also gerade transnationale,
Konzerne mehr Macht haben als Staaten. Das ist für mich halt der Fuß in die Tür dafür. Das möchte ich nicht.
Cyber Punk Mark.
Es war's. Also ich würde sagen, der äh unbestritten umstrittenste Teil ist wirklich die Sache mit den Schiedsgerichten.
Über die konkreten Auswirkungen der einzelnen äh Aspekte des äh Abkommens
ist, nur die Art und Weise, wie darüber dann letztlich entschieden werden soll, die ähm nährt auf jeden Fall,
ähm die Beunruhigung. So, wer so sagt, hat noch lange nicht fertig.
Kommen wir zur einfacheren äh Themen der äh der Konzernmacht über zivilgesellschaftliches Engagement. Ähm.
Das ist ein eine Meldung, die übrigens, das war, glaube ich, eines der ersten,
Internetdienstanbieter herantreten und ähm.
Ich äh ich erinnere da an den Fall, ähm der das,
des National Security Letters, der an Twitter gegangen ist, wo man irgendwie eine Liste von Informationen über ähm.
Noch ich glaube das waren die drei. Julien natürlich auch ähm haben wollte.
Und das war so so ein Serienbriefstyle, wo dann so drinsteht, wir wollen auch die Payment-Information von denen haben und das verriet ja schon da Twitter ja niemals von irgendjemandem Payment Informationen hat, weil es irgendwie,
Ist der äh sich nicht monetarisiert lässt und erst recht,
Da kam ja schon der Verdacht, auf dass es sich dabei eher umso äh National Security Serienbriefe handelte.
Und ähm,
Natürlich kam damals auch schon raus, dass äh dass Google und andere Institutionen sowas auch bekommen haben. Und jetzt ähm.
Wurde gerade von WikiLeaks äh behandelt, der Fall, ähm dass zweitausendzwölf ähm,
Das ist der Sprecher von ähm von Wiki Leaks,
äh Josef, äh dessen äh Position ich
gerade nicht parat habe. Ähm die haben auf deren E-Mails wurde also von Google im Namen der Strafverfolgung zweitausendzwölf zugegriffen
und das ist fand dann im Rahmen eines solchen äh National Security Letter statt und Google unterlag einem Gag Order, also einer Schweige
Verpflichtung, die jetzt ausgelaufen ist zweitausendvierzehn und hat,
jetzt dann ah deshalb jetzt die Person darüber in Kenntnis gesetzt. Also es war,
oder zweitausendfünfzehn haben wir ja jetzt schon. Also hat äh,
aber ich glaube die Benachrichtigung war zweitausendvierzehn, also haben gesagt, okay, hier übrigens vor zwei Jahren haben wir eure gesamten E-Mails äh den Strafverfolgungsbehörden gegeben und jetzt dürfen wir es euch das auch sagen. Bei Christin Raffenson waren's
dreiundvierzigtausend E-Mails.
Fällt mir natürlich ein, OK, man sieht hier ne den Diensteanbietern ist nicht zu trauen und man versteht auch, dass die Strafverfolgungsbehörden und Geheimdienste nervös werden, wenn die Diensteanbieter jetzt dafür sorgen, dass sie selbst die Mails ihrer Kunden nicht mehr lesen können
was Google im Übrigen auch
für die Zukunft plant, ja? Also die wollen Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung,
das Ding einbauen, weil äh Google eben auch kein
keinen Bock mehr hat, mit solchen Aktionen regelmäßig als der.
Ihre Werbung.
Genau, die brauchen, die brauchen schon den Klartext.
Web anzeigen.
Das geht. Äh du machst einfach, du machst so ein ähm.
Javascript in Schüsseln oder was?
Genau, also das Java Srip kann eine local Storage haben und dann lässt du halt quasi auf dem kleinen Rechner in Javascript den den Public-Endschlüsseln.
Wer dir den Private Key entschlüsseln und lädt den aber gleichzeitig danach wieder verschlüsselt ähm auf den Google-Server. Das heißt, du könntest dann trotzdem aus allen auf aus allen äh.
Aber wie kommt der private Schlüssel in.
Den generierst du einfach hinter, was das einzige Problem ist, die Entropie, die in Java Skript nicht vernünftig zur Verfügung steht.
Ja, weil weil das halt äh also das ist natürlich nicht die reine Leere, aber es,
wäre eine besonders schöne.
Äh Lösung eben in diesem Problem der Anbieterhaftung äh oder eben im Problem, dass dass der Anbieter eben diese Sachen rausgeben muss. Und wenn der Anbieter sagt, nee, das endet zu Ende Faschisten, da können wir gar nicht dran, selbst wenn wir wollen.
Aber es will Google ja nicht, weil Google ja also Inhalte basiert ähm Werbung schaltet, die analysieren ja wirklich die Mails. Von daher glaube ich klar könnte man machen, aber Google wäre jetzt nicht mein erster Verdächtiger für die Einführung da.
Whatsa,
mit die Texte Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung ähm einbauen lassen. Und offenkundig oder offenbar.
Ähm reichen Facebook die Metadaten aus und ist Facebook ähm bereit diese,
in die Kommunikation, dafür fallen zu lassen, dass sie den Marktanteil behalten und das Vertrauen der Nutzer,
in ihren Dienst stärken. Und ähm ich habe den Eindruck, dass sich diese,
dass sich das Kräfteverhältnis gerade zu Gunsten äh solcher Entscheidungen äh verschoben hat.
Obwohl, ich finde aus ökonomischer Sicht ist das schwierig, zu vergleichen, weil ähm gerade bei WhatsApp ich das Gefühl habe, dass ähm Facebook so ein bisschen seine Flanke gesichert hat. Und das
primäre Monitarisierungsding ist halt Facebook und nicht WhatsApp und das wird's wahrscheinlich auch in Zukunft nicht sein.
Wir werden sehen, ob und wie Google das macht. Ich weiß, dass es da Pläne.
Tatsächlich Schritte in diese Richtung machen, weil Google das sicherlich sehr, sehr peinlich ist und eine ganze Menge Google-Mitarbeiter nicht äh äh stolz erhobenen Hauptes rumrennen, wenn ausgerechnet ähm,
die Wiki Leaks Leute, die sich aus völlig unklaren Gründen mit ihren E-Mails Google anvertraut haben,
Also das ist äh journalistischen Quellenschutz. Ähm ich denke, dass die äh da jetzt nicht ernsthaft sich.
Ich, mir ist unklar, wie sie jemals äh ein Kugel-Mail-Account haben konnten. Ähm man könnte sich ja eigentlich damit rausreden, dass man den nicht benutzt hat oder nur privat oder was auch immer.
Oder aber äh das kann auch sein bei dem Guten Christin, dass das halt irgendwie dreiundvierzig,
aber der Punkt ist, wir haben hier wieder eine Meldung ähm.
Eben genau über diesen über diesen Zugriff auf die Daten bei den Diensteanbietern und die werden sich da irgendwie drum kümmern müssen und tun das ja jetzt auch. Ähm,
Ähm ansonsten, wie's dann äh Assanges, Anwältin, Melinda Taylor, daraufhin, dass äh ja unmenschlich behandelt würde,
weder das Sonnenlicht noch eine Klinik sehen darf
und gleichzeitig hat sie aber angekündigt, weil Großbritannien nämlich gesagt hat, sollte.
Ähm der europäische Haftbefehl gegen ihn aufgehoben werden und er aus der ähm,
Er ist ja,
geflohen und äh er hatte Auflagen, gegen die hat er verstoßen, er wird ja nicht straffrei äh drumherum kommen. Völlig unerheblich davon,
ob er, ob er in allen Punkten freigesprochen wird oder nicht. Ja, wenn ich als wenn ich unschuldig in U Haft bin
ja als kleiner Vergleich und ich breche aus diesem Gefängnis aus
weil ich im im Namen eines klassischen Actionfilmplotz meine Unschuld beweisen muss und das tue und dann irgendwie Hauptes mit dem Beweis zurückkomme, dass ich es nicht wahr, dann werd ich trotzdem noch vor Gericht stehen, weil ich aus weil ich äh aus aus der U-Haft ausgebrochen bin.
Die Linus Idetity.
Gut, also jetzt hat sie angekündigt, selbst wenn, selbst wenn man also,
kritisiert, dass er unmenschlich behandelt wird, weil er nicht da raus darf und,
selbst und dass er auch in Zukunft nicht da rauskommen wird. Okay.
Wobei natürlich diese, die Situation von Julian Assange wirklich äh bedauerlich ist. Das einzige, was ich mir noch schlimmer vorstellen könnte, ist wäre, wenn er irgendwie für den Rest seines Lebens äh in einem US-amerikanischen Militärgefängnis sitzen müsste, wie zum Beispiel,
das ist äh du sprichst auf Barred Brown an. Barred Brown.
Ist ein äh Journalist, der ähm jetzt grade in den USA ähm verurteilt wurde.
Zwar geht die Vorgeschichte schon ein bisschen,
aufgefallen sind. Und dann gab es ausgehend
die Gruppe, die dann für einige Monate relativ.
Frei, alle möglichen Webseiten und äh Firmen gehackt hat,
unter anderem und das war so der der größte oder der.
Ne, wie soll man das sagen? Der weitreichendste und politisch brisanteste Hack von Leilzeck ähm der Angriff auf äh Stretch Four, also die die Firma, die sich mit ähm,
mit mit internationalen, wirtschaftlichen und diplomatischen Auseinandersetzungen beschäftigen. Äh und die ihre in Analysen und Informationen ähm ich glaube im,
Ein Wirtschaftsintelligence Dienst sein, ja? Nicht unbedingt ein Geheimdienst, aber ähm.
Nicht nur Wirtschaft, sondern generell Politik. So.
Genau. Da kann man, konnte man sich irgendwie äh anmelden. Und da da sind halt äh da ist nullsteck reinmarschiert und in diesem Fall, der war.
Das FBI zu diesem Zeitpunkt schon Hector, Monfigur, alias Sabu, einen der
eine der führenden äh Persönlichkeiten in diesem ganzen Bereich ähm an den Eiern hatte. Die saßen quasi die ganze Zeit neben dem und haben ihn ähm.
Haben ihm über die Schulter geschaut und haben ihn haben quasi Kenntnis davon gehabt, dass dieser Angriff auf Strator,
Also haben sich angeschaut, dass er stattfindet und wollten quasi ähm.
Das billigend in Kauf genommen, um endlich etwas gegen diese Leute auch in der Hand zu haben.
Gleichzeitig war, hatte Lalsex zu diesem Zeitpunkt
Unter anderem, ich glaube, fünf Millionen E-Mails dann später veröffentlicht wurden.
Das heißt hatte, hatte da eine Kooperation mit mit Wiki Le,
und die FBI-Agenten interessierten sich, glaube ich, auch dafür,
der nicht eventuell Julien Assange
diesem Hack angestiftet hat, weil dann hätten sie endlich was gegen Julian Assange in der Hand, weil er Dampf ähm nicht mehr sich darauf berufen könnte, dass alle diese Daten irgendwo herkommen und plötzlich bei ihm in der Imbox landen und er ist quasi als journalistische Tätigkeit
betreibt diese Sachen dann auch der Welt zugänglich zu machen, weil er eben eine,
relativ kompromisslose Veröffentlichungsstrategie fährt,
und nun auch noch ähm ein ähm,
ursprünglich eigentlich ein Journalist mit einfach nur äh guten Verbindungen und dem Vertrauen von enormem ist, so dass er ähm.
Von anderen Medien, wo der dann teilweise als als Sprecher von,
titelt, äh was aber äh stets äh von sich gewiesen hat. Und im Rahmen dieses ähm,
äh rannte dann ähm das F,
und ähm er kam dann in U-Haft
und äh wurde zunächst zwölf Anklagepunkten ausgesetzt, von denen die insgesamt äh so auf ein äh auf eine Summe von einhundertfünf Jahren Knast gekommen wären,
Ähm.
Dann haben sich äh Reporter ohne Grenzen und die IFF äh protestieren in diesem Fall eingemischt,
Auch auf dem einunddreißig zu drei äh waren äh Transparente, die seine Freilassung forderten durchaus präsent,
Und äh zuletzt wurde diese ganze Anklage dann eingedampft auf drei Anklagepunkte mit insgesamt achteinhalb Jahren äh Höchststrafmaß, wenn man alles addiert.
Schnäppchen.
Na ja, ich meine, von hundertfünf auf acht ist schon echt schon mal ganz korrekt. Ne und jetzt ist ganz interessant, welche
Verbliebenen das denn jetzt waren, ja,
Ahnung, der äh dieser und jener FBI-Beamte äh ist ein Arschloch, den.
Mist.
Schaden, ich beabsichtige den zu Schaden.
Haben wir jetzt schon eigentlich jemanden bedroht? Haben wir jetzt schon sind wir schon zu weit gegangen? Ähm.
Dann äh das Behindern einer Hausdurchsuchung, äh weil er mit Hilfe seiner Mutter ein,
vor den Ermittlern versteckt hat, die sein Haus durchsucht haben,
Er sagt natürlich, er ist Journalist und hat das zum Schutz seiner Quellen getan, aber die sagen, die äh die die Ankläger haben gesagt, nee, du hast damit unsere Hausdurchsuchung.
Ähm.
Wusste nicht, dass man, wenn die einem die Tür eintreten und und alle Schränke aufreißen, dass man da auch noch irgendwie sie dabei unterstützen muss.
Ja. Ähm ist mir auch neu.
Ähm.
Und dann, er habe nach dem Stretch for Hack mit Verantwortlichen des Unternehmens Kontakt aufgenommen und sich als Vermittler zu enormen Angeboten
Und das ist natürlich durchaus eine eine Grenze, die,
hier da überschritten hat. Aber jetzt kommt's,
Also das ist ja immer noch nicht immer noch nicht, äh also Familiertätigkeit ist ja immer noch nicht irgendwie etwas strafbares, aber,
Ihm wird zur Last gelegt, er solle dabei die Behörden auf eine falsche Fährte gelockt haben. Denn als er quasi als Journalist und.
Oder Stadt vor angeboten hat, dass er eine Vermillerolle übernehmen könne, habe er die,
inzwischen schon äh zu zehn Jahren verurteilt wurde, weil er von Hector Mundzegur verpfiffen wurde, gezielt verschleiert,
Und damit mache er sich zum Helfer der Tat. Also das heißt, okay, er hat irgendwie auf Drogenentzug einen FBI-Beamten in einem YouTube-Video bedroht,
Er hat bei einer Hausdurchsuchung einen Computer versteckt,
und er hat ähm in in,
einer privaten Vermittlerrolle zu einer zu einem enormes Opfer nicht.
Der gesagt, wer der der wahre Täter ist, sondern habe diese Identität verschleiert und sich somit zu einem Helfer nach der Tat gemacht.
Das sind tatsächlich die Anklagepunkte, äh denen er jetzt ausgesetzt war. Zwei Jahre war er schon in U-Haft, um auf diese,
auf dieses Urteil zu warten, wurde nun zu insgesamt dreiundsechzig Monaten Haft verurteilt, also knapp fünf Jahren.
Aha, wofür das jetzt? Für die emotionalen Schmerz.
Ich denke, gegenüber gegenüber Strat vor.
Ach so, ich dachte, der FBI-Agent beleidigt.
Das weiß ich nicht, also da muss ich sagen, da habe ich nicht genau geschaut. Also das kann genauso gut sein, dass es einfach nur an den FBI-Agenten geht. Ähm.
Oder ans Schiedsgericht.
Und das alles vor dem Hintergrund, dass er sich ein,
schon zu allem schuldig bekannt hatte, um das Strafenmass irgendwie zu lindern.
So, das ist natürlich ähm wie würde man sowas nennen?
Genau, ein Exempel, das da statuiert wurde in Form eines sehr drakonischen Urteils gegen diesen ähm jungen Mann und ich denke, das ist ein ganz klares Signal an einerseits Aktivisten.
Andererseits Journalisten, die mit ihnen arbeiten oder die überhaupt mit arbeiten, ja?
Also wie zwei dieser Anklagepunkte sind offenkundiger Quellenschutz eines äh Journalisten.
Ähm für die, für die ihr jetzt da äh.
Das andere ist eine im besten Fall eine Beleidigung, ne? Oder eine Bedrohung.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das YouTube-Video jetzt nicht gesehen, ähm.
Was wir so gemacht haben.
Keine Ahnung, ich hab's halt nicht gesehen, aber ich kann mir, ich halte ja nach wie vor, ne, also ähm was Leute auf YouTube.
Wohl deine Quellen nicht.
Ja, glaube ich auch nicht. Aber du meinst, YouTube ist ja sowieso.
Nein, ich ich halte,
Also gerade in einem Land, der bei der in dem Redefreiheit so groß geschrieben wird, wie in den USA,
ist natürlich erstaunlich, dass jemand für etwas, was er in einem offen, also in diesem Video offenbar auch erkennbar nicht besonders guten,
geistigen Zustand formuliert.
Dass daraus ihm einen Strick gedreht wird. Ja.
Wenn man anfangen würde, jetzt alle mal einzuknasten, die irgendwen irgendwie auf YouTube beleidigt haben oder Kommentarspalte euch getreut haben, sondern.
Also Beleidigung, Beleidigung ist ja so.
Beleidigung ist ja eh so ein Ding, also Beleidigung kriegst du,
allenfalls durch äh äh gegen Polizisten, ne, oder oder sonstige staatliche Würdenträger, sonst wenn wenn nicht jetzt sagt Tim du Arschloch.
Sack Nase.
Nee, das ist ja eine Meinungsäußerung. Wenn du jetzt sagst, äh Till ist äh, Tim, ich haue dir gleich eine rein, wenn du das und das nicht, das wäre eine Bedrohung, das wäre ja noch.
Bedrohung, ja. Dann könnte es.
Das wäre schon mal.
Traust du dir eh nicht?
Nee, das treue ich mich und nicht. Bedrohung mache ich nicht.
Wir regeln das vor der Tür.
Wir klären das vorm Schiedsgericht. Na ja, also ich finde das sehr ähm.
Es ist natürlich schon ein ein schockierendes Urteil, wobei man jetzt auch dazu sagen muss, dass er, dass das jetzt.
Barad Brown da sicherlich an einer Grenze,
ja ähm was was jetzt irgendwie seine journalistische Tätigkeit angeht. Aber es ist ähm,
Ganz offensichtlich, dass die ähm amerikanische Justiz da jetzt auch echt klar zeigen will, ne, hier Freunde, so. Äh Sachen liegen oder so, das ist ein äh da da begebt ihr euch auf auf sehr dünnes Eis.
Zehn Jahre Haft äh Barack Brown jetzt quasi etwas über fünf Jahre Haft.
Hector Monzegur, der ähm zumindest ähm Jeremy Hamilt hier ans Messer geliefert hat, freier Mann, ne?
Ja, so sowas soll ja in Deutschland bald auch kommen. Es soll ja ein Gesetz kommen, damit die ganzen V-Männer, die äh,
Jean-Provokateur in irgendwelchen Bewegungsspielen, andere Leute zu Straftaten aufrufen, also quasi was,
gelaufen ist, ähm dass sie im Nachhinein eine Straffreiheit bekommen, weil sonst kann man ja nicht mehr arbeiten, ne. Ja.
Land of the free.
Na, dass, dass, dass, das hat auch wieder zwei Effekte, ne? Das führt zu einer ziemlich.
Die quasi weit über oder ein Misstrauen, das weit über den eigentlichen,
übers eigentliche Risiko hinausgeht, weil du siehst, an diesem Beispiel lernst du eigentlich, dass du selbst dem Anführer deiner eigenen Bewegung,
das war oder ein Anführer ist gut, aber einer der einer der schillerndsten, wie nennt man das,
Primus, Ante Paris oder was? Der Beste untergleichen oder sowas, dass du selbst den nicht mehr nicht mehr trauern kannst, ja?
Sorry, ich bin ja ich ich bitte das mit meiner bildungsfernen Sozialisation zu entschuldigen, dass ich.
Gibt da noch andere krasse Beispiele. Habt ihr von den Tierrechtsaktivisten in Großbritannien gehört,
eziehung und geheiratet und alles drum und dran und irgendwann,
diesen Moment mal, der war halt nur hier, um halt unsere Tiere extremer radikale Tierrechtsbewegungen
unterwandern, hoch, ja und ähm ja die klagt jetzt, ich weiß gar nicht, hat die jetzt schon Recht bekommen, die hat auf Schadensersatz geklagt, Schmerzensgeld, obwohl ich mir da denke, also so ein,
das kann man gar, das kann man nicht mit Geld bezahlen, also das das ist echt erwartig.
Vor allem, weil das waren ja echt irgendwie so ein paar äh also ich meine, die waren jetzt wirklich keine Bedrohung für
für die für das gemeinschaftliche Zusammenleben, das waren halt irgendwie so ein paar
Tierschutz-Hippies, ne? Und die wurden da irgendwie massiv unterwandert von V-Männern, die da äh ja, also das war,
Das ist wirklich, das sind wirklich skurrile Geschichten, ähm die aber leider eben eine Signalwirkung haben, die ähm,
auf die es, glaube ich, auch bei diesen bei diesen Urteilen geht.
Genau, bei Barrett Brown. Ja, äh,
zu hoffen, dass das noch in irgendeiner Form eine Revision erfährt, auch wenn's jetzt danach erstmal nicht aussieht.
So, nach nur einer anderthalb Stunde kommen wir zu unserem beliebten Teil der Kurzmeldung.
Genau da haben wir einmal jetzt eine, also das ist wirklich Katharina, dich interessiert ja Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Kaum, seit zweitausendsieben kaum.
Die EU? Nein, ich glaube, es wurde nur gefordert.
Ach so, genau, äh ich weiß da gar nicht mehr den aktuellen.
Der CDU wahrscheinlich,
ja nicht sein, dass und.
Aber jetzt haben sie gesagt, sie sie planen auf jeden Fall keine neue Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Also aktueller Stand, dass das VDSometer momentan äh in dieser Woche keine neue Vorratsdatenspeicherung auf EU-Ebene geplant.
Vielleicht kann man ja so ein Barometer einführen, so mit Orange, Rot und Gelb. So äh wie ist der Stand der Vorratsdatenspeisung? Weil ganz ehrlich, also das verfolgt uns wie so ein wiederkehrender Zombie,
länger feiern uns ähm,
na ja also die Frage ist halt, was ist nächste Woche, beziehungsweise da laufen ja im Hintergrund auf jeden Fall noch Evaluationen, inwiefern man es doch noch,
irgendwie mit dem Urteil vereinbaren kann und da wäre ich mir nicht so sicher, ob das jetzt so der Hoffnungsschimmer ist.
Zumal es hier um eine Äußerung der Kommissarin für den
für die Harmonisierung des Binnenmarktes geht, ist ja immer eine interessante Aspekt, der vergessen wurde oder gerne mal vergessen wird, Vorratsdatenspeicherung sollte ja auch zur Harmonisierung des europäischen Binnenmarktes äh
führen, auf das äh überall gleiche Überwachungsmaßgaben äh gelten und nicht etwa,
Der Binnenmarkt äh durch ein Ungleichgewicht der Überwachungsregulation äh behindert würde.
Was ja total gut funktioniert hat. In Polen wird beispielsweise zwei Jahre lang
ähm auf Vorrats äh gespeichert und in anderen Ländern halt nur sechs Monate und so weiter und so fort. Also diese,
Argument der Vereinheitlichung und ich glaube, das ist auch mittlerweile auch bei der Kommission angefangen.
Angekommen ist halt ähm Schwachsinn, hat nicht funktioniert, war anscheinend Argument,
Es gab mal Bestrebungen, ähm die,
Vorratsdatenspeicherung zu harmonisieren, dass man ähm sagt, okay, wenn wir jetzt eine Revaluation, eine neue Richtlinie vielleicht machen, das war noch voll im Urteil
dass man da gleiche Speicherfristen einzieht und so weiter und so fort, was aber auch wieder schwierig ist, weil dann Länder wie Polen sagen, so nee, aber eigentlich brauchen wir drei Jahre, wenn wenn du uns so fragst, so, ne? Und von daher ja, schwierige Debatte, ich werde noch Albträume haben.
Äh Urteil offensichtlich wenig Möglichkeiten sieht und auch so ein vorpreschender äh Oettinger, der dann,
seinen politischen CDU-Ambitionen dann gerne mal sowas fordert, wird da nicht äh ausreichend ernst genommen äh und äh überhaupt auch äh man verweist da drauf, dass er
ja, können ja alle nach wie vor ihre nationalen Regelungen äh finden, solange sie mit dem EuGH-Gesetz vereinbar sind, was ja eigentlich kaum welche sind. Und ähm,
der EU Kommission ist das wohl alles egal und wenn man sich halt den Zustand in der aktuellen ähm.
Debatte der äh Regierungskoalition in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland anschaut, dann hat man auch das Gefühl da gibt
wird dann äh kommt dann der Herr und sagt ja, man muss ja da unbedingt mal was tun, damit
CSU ein bisschen Ruhe gibt und äh will auf irgendwelche Vorschläge äh
machen und der Heiko Maas, der mir irgendwie in dieser ganzen Debatte sehr gut,
Feld, wie ich finde, weil er da ziemlich klar Position bezieht.
Däumchen drehen und sagt so.
Genau, macht die Sabine und der CDU fluchen sie wahrscheinlich, weil sie sich, weil sie dachten, jetzt sind sie die endlich los und jetzt haben sie den Heiko irgendwie.
Da bin ich mir halt immer noch nicht so sicher. Also ich habe mir Heiko Maas ja vorher so ein bisschen angeguckt, was ist das für ein Typ? Und da habe ich, ich glaube, der erste zweite Link, den ich gefunden habe, war irgendwas zu wir müssen diese Killerspiele stärker kontrollieren und ähm von daher so unvoreingenommen positiv
bedient, so, ne? Dass man in der SPD signalisiert sogar, wir wollen über fünfundzwanzig Prozent hinaus, wir sind die Volkspartei, nehmen wir noch die Leute, die jetzt so ein bisschen Schiss haben nach den Anschlägen, geben wir ihnen irgendein,
irgendetwas woran sie sich festhalten können, wie die Vorratsdatenspeicherung inszenieren, kleinen innerparteilichen Konflikt nach außen hin, um ähm in den Medien ein bisschen zu sagen, wir machen was.
Gut, mit solchen Verschwörungstheorien kann man natürlich kommen. Ich glaube, Sigmar Gabriel ist da ein bisschen.
Ist, also das ist keine Verschwörungstheorie, würde ich nicht sagen. Jede Partei bedient halt unterschiedliche Wählerklientel und.
Nee, aber jetzt,
wer jetzt sozusagen wofür steht so, da sehe ich dann halt doch äh so das Findchen im Wind scheint mir dann doch eher Sigmar Gaurie zu sein, während die Position von Heiko Maas bisher eigentlich relativ klar war und zwar, dass im Übrigen auch von Tag eins an. Also kaum, dass Herr Justizminister geworden ist
Es war, glaube ich, sein allererstes Statement, ne. Ich erinnere mich noch, wo dann äh dann gleich ein Gespräch mit ihm geführt hat
weil er dann irgendwie so forsch so ja hier in die VDS ist ja tot, lassen wir mal sein und dann so wir müssen reden,
dann gleich so aus der CDU-Fraktion. Da wurde auch ein bisschen geredet und wurde so ein bisschen so ein Wischiwaschi ja im Rahmen der Gesetzgebung bla streben wir weiterhin an und so so eine Sprachregelung. Aber eigentlich hat er sich da nicht groß dran gehalten.
Äh ganz äh gut, weil das irgendwie relativ klare Worte waren und.
Also weiter so Heiko Maas ähm bravo.
Genau.
Dann hat der EU-Rechtsausschuss äh seine,
eineinhalb Jahre während der Aufarbeitung der AdWords Norden Enthüllung abgeschlossen.
Ähm und zwar der EU-Rechtsausschuss des Europarats. Wo ich mir,
mich mich habe aufklären lassen, dass der Europarat kein EU, kein reines EU-Organ ist, sondern ein europäischer Staatenbund, dem auch Nicht-EU-Mitglieder wie Russland und die Türkei angehören.
Erinnere mich, das war in einer Folge von ähm Fokus Europa war das von der jungen Dame, die du dazu oder die.
Genau, weil das es gibt, ne, also das, das, das muss man echt auseinanderhalten. Also es gibt das EU-Geflecht, es besteht halt aus Kommission, Parlament,
Rad. Das sind sozusagen die drei großen EU-Institutionen, die sich ja auch immer auf alles einigen müssen. Dann gibt's noch einen Europarat. Das hat aber damit überhaupt nichts zu tun. Ist was ganz anderes.
Also Rat der Europäischen Union versus Europarat, ja?
Unglaublich, unglaublich.
So ist das.
Ja, ja, es gelingt ihnen auch.
Wir brauchen internationalen Vereinbarungen äh eine eine äh Berufung auf die äh Menschenrechtskater, der äh Europäischen Union
und wir sollen einen ordentlichen rechtlichen Schutz vor Massenüberwachung,
aber bis bis wir den haben, äh bleibt uns nichts,
Peter Optik und der ist von den Christdemokraten, das heißt, wenn man, sobald man, selbst Christdemokraten, mal in ein,
Gremium schickt, dass nichts zu entscheiden hat, dann äh machen die auch vernünftige Berichte, ja. Also es ist sehr, sehr interessant, wie das Setting einer äh eines politischen Gremiums eben auch verändert, äh wie,
Wie frei und wie vernünftig man sich da einfach mal äußert, weil,
Eine sehr rationale und sinnvolle Erwägung, die da getätig
nicht nur weil es äh meine äh weil sie sich mit meiner Einschätzung deckt, sondern auch weil sie äh sich mit Argumenten äh und äh so auseinandersetzt im Gegensatz zu vielen anderen. Das also ganz interessant vom Europarat.
Letzte Woche vorm Spiegel, ein relativ größerer Teil,
Dokumente gedampft. Da wurde.
In dem begleitenden Artikel auch gar nicht so viel zu geschrieben. Also nicht jedes dieser Dokumente, was sich dann online widerfand, äh wurde im im Spiegel jetzt großartig genaustens erwähnt.
Und da fand sich dann ähm,
Also Spiegel schrieb, das wäre der Quellcode, aber es war natürlich nicht der Quellcot, sondern das war das Kompilat,
wahrscheinlich,
draufgeschaut. Es war auf jeden Fall quasi ein Ausschnitt aus einem,
Logger aus den Snowden Leaks. Dann haben sie gesagt, dieser,
Ist aus dem Besitz von äh ist ein ist ein NSA-Tool, ja? Aus dem Fundus von AdWords Norden,
Hier Veröffentlichung auf so 'ner PDF-Datei irgendwie auf Seite zwanzig oder so, ne? War wahrscheinlich auch kein Zufall, dass sie das so gemacht haben und dann meldeten sich ähm Forscher,
zu Wort, die.
Regine, Regina.
Das Ding halt, Engin, Regien, keine Ahnung, der, der, der, der, des, äh,
die Trojaner Suite äh der NSA.
Und die haben festgestellt, dass dieser Key-Locker.
Cordfragmente dieses Keyloggers sich auch in ihrem äh Redging ähm,
befunden haben. Ja, wir hatten ja gesagt, Red Gin war so modular, man konnte sich das quasi zusammenbauen, wie man's gerade brauchte. Und das oder der,
Das Schöne an dieser Stelle ist jetzt, dass dadurch die Urheberschaft,
weil wir quasi einmal das aus der freien Wildbahn.
Also freie Wildbahn in dem Fall ähm Computer unserer Abgeordneten und Telekommunikationsanbieter oder so. Und ähm,
auf der anderen Seite dieses dieses diesen Key-Locker
von Edward Snowden haben und die halt übereinstimmen und damit,
ist bewiesen, dass die NSA und des äh GCHQ hinter diesen,
Trojaner und hinter diesen Angriffen,
das ist nicht immer so bei Cyberwaffen und das war bei Redin halt auch ähm naheliegend
Projekten über die in den Snowde-Dokumenten gesprochen wurde, sodass der Verdacht nahe lag, aber jetzt ist er bewiesen, dass er immer nochmal einen Unterschied.
Schön, endlich kann man mal was beweisen hier.
Ja, das wär, also das ist eigentlich ganz schön, wenn man jetzt, jetzt könnte man, also wenn man jetzt in so einem Land leben würde, in dem man sich um die Verfolgung von solchen Sachen äh äh bemühen würde, dann könnte man jetzt an dieser Stelle sagen, es gibt einen Beweis.
Der Generalbundesanwalt wird das auch wahrscheinlich nie so sehen.
Jetzt, also das wäre jetzt sowas, was man dem Generalbundesanwalt mal als Anfangsverdacht andienen könnte, ja. Äh um mal zu gucken, wie er darauf reagiert.
Ach, da muss er ja, da muss er ja aufstehen und Kühlschrank aufmachen, Füße anstrengen.
Das war auch der mit dem Versprecher, mit äh die wir haben keine Beweise, dass die NASA irgendwas so und alles,
NASA.
Da hat er recht. Die NASA,
das ist das ist wirklich 'ne Verschwörungstheorie, dass die NASA hier bei uns spioniert, dass.
Mittlerweile gibt's übrigens ähm über zweitausend Klagen von Bürgern, die nicht verfolgt werden in diesem Bereich. Also der Typ hat einen lauen Tag.
Er könnte sich viel Arbeit machen, aber wie gesagt, es wird halt so, gibt keine Beweise.
So und damit werden wir am am Sende der Endung.
Ende der Sendung angekommen.
Und es bleibt mir an dieser Stelle äh nur zu danken, wenn ich das an diese, wenn ich das jetzt schon darf oder möchtet ihr noch eure, möchtet ihr noch jemanden grüßen?
Ich möchte meinen Prof grüßen.
Habe ich, dass ich, ich habe das nicht vergessen.
Ich danke einfach nur äh zwei notorischen Wiederholungstätern.
Das sind die schlimmsten.
Das sind die besten und zwar äh Benjamin und Till. Die wissen Bescheid.
Wissen Bescheid. Ihr wisst Bescheid.
Und jetzt darfst du Katha danken.
Ja, Katar, vielen Dank.
Danke, also wollt ihr ach, ach danke, kein Ding.
Com? Naja, wie viel bist du denn so unterwegs? Du bist ja eigentlich in Hamburg, äh aber du reist viel.
Nee, nee, nee, ich bin gar nicht in Hamburg.
Bis gar nicht in Hamburg, ist alles nur.
Ich verschleiere das immer so, wo ich eigentlich wohne, ist.
Ich dachte jetzt so äh.
Gestern war ich in Hamburg, ähm deshalb wollte ich auch nochmal im äh nicht mein Freund, mein Prof grüßen. Könnt ihr das schneiden.
Nee.
Ja
Ja, auf jeden Fall möchte ich meinen Prof grüßen. Er war ich gestern. Ich war gestern in Hamburg und schreibe gerade meine Masterarbeit und ja, dann dank ich der S-Bahn, dass sie zu spät gekommen ist. Und euch danke ich's nicht, weil ihr keinen Kaffee hattet.
Ja, wir sind richtig fiese Säue, super. Kaffeemaschine. Ja, aber da ist gerade.
Ohne ordentliches Presswerk ist hier keinem kein kein Boden gutzumachen bei Katar.
Ja, ihr hört von meinem Anwalt und bis demnächst.
Legen wir, legen wir dem Schiedsgericht vor.
Jo, das war's. Danke fürs Zuhören, tschüss, bis bald. Tschau, tschau.
Ciao, ciao.